EVERYONE PURSUANT TO SECTION
FIVE OF ARTICLE FIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THE
ASSEMBLY SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
THE OFFICE OF THE SECRETARY OF-STATE IS MEETING TO CONSIDER
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S NOMINATION OF
DR SHIRLEY WEBER TO FILL THE
VACANCY AT THE OFFICE OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. TODAY'S
HEARING ALLOWS THIS COMMITTEE
TO EXAMINE THE GOVERNOR'S
NOMINATION MORE CLOSELY AND
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PUBLIC TO COMMENT ON DR WEBER'S
NOMINATION. THE COMMITTEE HAS
RECEIVED LETTERS OF SUPPORT
FROM A NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS
AND WE WILL POST THIS LIST OF
THOSE SUPPORTING ORGANIZATIONS.
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBPAGE.
COMMITTEE STAFF WE PLEASE TAKE
THE ROLE AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
BERMAN HERE LOW. LARA HERE
ALLEN. READ. IF YOU CURRENTLY
HAVE A GREAT THE YOU VERY MUCH
MISS BY EXPLAINING THE FOR
TODAY. WILL STAR WITH THE
OPENING REMARK BY THE NUMBER O
THE COMMITTEE THIS WILL BE
FOLLOWED OPENING OUR BY DA
WEBER. WE HAVE A PANEL OF THREE
WE WITH US. TRICIA WEBER THE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY CLERK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. OF COURSE IN
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. ROBERT
LAPSLEY PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE.
AND MERRY CHRISTMAS THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. FOLLOWING
THIS PANEL WILL OPEN THE
HEARINGFOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AFTER THE PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
MOVE TO QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
DELIBERATION. DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE
WORN IN PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. TODAY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TWO OF THE
STATE CAPITOL WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACE AND- THERE
ARE STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF OUR AGENDA TODAY
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE.
TIME I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC COULD NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. THE
THREE PANELISTS THAT WILL BE
PRESENTING THEIR ORGANIZATIONAL
PERSPECTIVES FOR THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE PARTICIPATING VIA VIDEO
CONFERENCE. MEMBERS WILL BE
ABLE TO WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY
LONG LIFE AND ASK THEM
QUESTIONS. WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF THE HEARING. THE
CALLING THAT NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AGAIN THE CALL IN NUMBER.
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO- OH TWO.
AGAIN ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR
COMPUTER SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN A WE SUGGEST THAT
YOU DO SO BEFORE WE GET TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF THE
AGENDA. THE OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALLBACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MOOD
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST. AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUNDED
DISTORTION. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT WE ALL FACE. WITH
THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS OUT OF THE
WAY WE WILL MOVE ON OF THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA. AS I
MENTIONED ABOVE THE PURPOSE OF
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO CONSIDER
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S DOMINATION OF
DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER. TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S NEXT SECRETARY OF
STATE. CALIFORNIA'S PREVIOUS
SECRETARY OF STATE ALEX
PADILLA. RESIGNED THAT POSITION
EIGHT DAYS AGO WHEN HE WAS
FORMALLY APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM TO REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
IN THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
OUR NATION HAS JUST WHETHER A
VERY DIFFICULT ELECTION YEAR
THE BEGAN WITH THE PRIMARY IN
MARCH JUST BEFORE WE FULLY
APPRECIATED THE IMPACT OF CODED.
AND CONCLUDED NOT AS WE
EXPECTED IN NOVEMBER BUT JUST
EARLIER THIS MONTH WHEN
CONGRESS ACCEPTED THE RESULTS
OF THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE. ONE
OF THE MANY LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THAT FROM TWENTY TWENTY IS
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A
STRONG AND DEDICATED LEADER AS
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE. JUST
WEEKS AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY. WE WATCHED IN HORROR
AS WISCONSINITES WERE FORCED TO
VOTE IN PERSON IN THEIR PRIMARY
ELECTION. STANDING FOR HOURS IN
LINES THAT STRETCH FOR MILES
WILL KOBE CASES WERE STEADILY
CLIMBING. DESPITE THE BEST
EFFORTS OF ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
THOUSANDS OF VOTERS WHO
REQUESTED ABSENTEE BALLOTS DID
NOT RECEIVE THEM IN TIME TO
VOTE AND RETURN THE BY ELECTION
DAY. THEY WERE EFFECTIVELY
DISENFRANCHISED. NOT ONLY DID
OUR FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
MOVE SWIFTLY TO HELP US PREPARE
FOR AN ELECTION DURING A ONCE
IN A CENTURY PANDEMIC. AND
AVOID THE PROBLEMS WE WITNESSED
IN OTHER STATES. BUT HE ALSO
OVERSAW AN ELECTION LIKE NO
OTHER. WE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY WE MAIL THE
BALLOT TO EVERY ACTIVE
REGISTERED VOTER. IN THE STATE
AND MAINTAINED IN PERSON VOTING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE THAT
NEEDED THAT OPTION. WITHOUT THE
STEADY LEADERSHIP OUR SECRETARY
OF STATE AND COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS WE COULD HAVE FACED
MANY OF THE SAME CHALLENGES OF
OTHER STATES. INSTEAD
CALIFORNIA EMBRACED VOTING BY
MAIL AND WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
TURNOUT IN NEARLY SEVENTY YEARS.
BUT THE SECRETARY OF STATE IS
ABOUT MORE THAN JUST ELECTIONS
AND ALL DEFERRED TO MY CO CHAIR
TO DISCUSS THE VITAL ROLE WITH
REGARD TO BUSINESS MATTERS.
HOWEVER I WOULD BE NEGLIGENT
NOT TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE IS IN A
POSITION TO STEP IN ON OTHER
IMPORTANT MATTERS I SENATOR
PEDIA DID IN HELPING TO LEAD
OUR CENSUS EFFORTS. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH SENATOR PER DO OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS ON BOTH
ELECTIONS IN CENSUS EFFORTS.
ONE OF THE THINGS I MOST
APPRECIATED ABOUT HIM. WAS THIS
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH. IN HIS
VIEW IN THE LEGISLATURE AS A
PARTNER IN THESE EFFORTS. NOT
AS AN OBSTACLE OR KNOWING
OBLIGATION. THIS PRODUCTIVE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP LED TO
MUCH BETTER RESULTS FOR ALL
FORTY ALL FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY THAT'S WHAT MATTERS.
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH DR WEBBER OVER THE
PAST FOUR YEARS AS WELL. I KNOW
WERE TO BE A STRONG VOICE FOR
COMMUNITIES IN NEED A
THOUGHTFUL LEADER ON THE MOST
CRITICAL ISSUES OF THE DAY.
FROM EDUCATION TO ELECTIONS TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. AND
THE ONE PERSON THAT COMMANDS
THE ATTENTION OF ALL COLLEAGUES
WHEN SHE CHOOSES TO SPEAK ON
THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY.
CONFIRMING DR WEBBER WOULD BE A
HUGE LOSS TO THE ASSEMBLY. BUT
A MUCH GREATER WIN FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. ON A MORE
PERSONAL NOTE MY STAFF MY STAFF
HAS THE DEEPEST RESPECT AND
ADMIRATION FOR DR WEBER.
THEY'VE INFORMED ME THAT UPON
DR MEMBERS DEPARTURE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY FOR SOME OF THEM I
WOULD FINALLY BE THEIR FAVORITE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT THE AG I GUESS. I'D
LIKE TO TURN THINGS OVER TO MY
COACH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW
TO MAKE ANY OPENER OPENING
REMARKS THAT HE HAS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR OF WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. HAVE BEFORE IS
THE FORMER CHAIR OF THE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE IN MISS
WEBER. AS WELL AS MYSELF
SERVING AS THE PAST CHAIR OF
THAT COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE
CURRENT YEAR. IN MR BERMAN A
WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY.
LEADERSHIP THE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THIS S
BY CAMEL BY CAMEL PROCESS AND
REPRESENTING THE DIVERSITY. OF
ALL OF US TO ENSURE THAT THIS
IS A PROCESS TO WHICH WE CAN
HELP EXPEDITE THE PROCESS TO
EVERY DAY CALIFORNIANS SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ALIKE- AND THE STEWARD
OF PUBLIC TRUST AND- WE HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF SERVING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. IN THIS
CAPACITY. UNDER A NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT WE'VE OUTLINED-
THUS FAR TO POSE AS QUESTIONS
AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOU AND YOUR TEAM TO HELP
PROVIDE THAT. DETAIL BACKGROUND
I LOOK FOR TO THE DIALOGUE THAT
WE HAVE AHEAD OF US AND IN TURN
THIS BACK TO. CULTURE MR BERMAN
GREAT THANK YOU LOW. OVER NO I
THINK BOTH OF YOUR REALLY
STATED VERY WELL BUT I WANTED
TO AT LEAST A LEAD DOCTOR NO
HOW MUCH- I RESPECT HER AND HER
LEADERSHIP OF THE KIND
LEADERSHIP THAT ARE TO SEE AN
END QUITE- TO KNOW WE TO HIT
THE SWITCH INTO IT TO THE NEXT
THE ISSUE IS NOT BEING A- TO
SERVICE NOT ON OF YOU. THE HIGH
LEVEL OF PROFESSIONAL THAT
YOU'VE YOUR CELL AS LETTER- BUT
ALSO COMMUNITY THAT FOLLOWS AND
THAT YOU REPRESENT AND YOU HAVE
NOT YIELDED FROM THE TOUGH
ISSUES YOU STEPPED UP WHEN
OTHERS WOULD NOT ARE YOU HAVE
HAD TO TAKE YOUR SETBACKS BUT
YOU PRESSED FORWARD AND I WANT
YOU TO KNOW HOW PROUD I AM OF
THE. THANK YOU MISTER- MY
LEADER READ. THANK YOU FOR I
WANT TO THANK THE SPEAKER FOR A
POINT ME ALONG WITH COLLEAGUES
TO SET ON SUCH NUMBER. SPECIAL
CONFIRMATION COMMITTEE AND TO
THE CHAIRS WHO'VE OPENED US UP
THIS THIS EVENING THIS AFTER.
FIRST I WANT TO COME. MY FOR
THANK SURELY WE- FOR HIS HIS
STORY POINT. SECRETARY STATE OR
NOMINATIONS WE'RE GOING TO GET
TO THE POINT. CLIFORNIA'S LAW
SYSTEM LIKE THAT OF MY OTHER
STATES TO SPEAK AND- CHALLENGES
FROM COMBATING MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS TO STRENGTHENING
VOTER CONFIDENCE IN OUR
ELECTIONS. OUR NEXT SECRETARY
STATE HAS A MONUMENTAL JOB
AHEAD OF HER. SHE WILL NEED TO
BALANCE THE NEED FOR ELECTION
SECURITY WHILE ENSURING THAT WE
ARE MAKING OUR ELECTIONS
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL VOTERS. SHE
WILL NEED TO BE AN ADVOCATE FOR
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES AND
FOR VOTERS SEEKING ACCESS. WELL
DR WEBER'S WORK IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND MORE SPECIFICALLY AS PART
OF THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE IS
THE GREATEST TESTAMENT TO HER
UNCOMPROMISED COMMITMENT TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND TO THE
SAFE AND INCLUSIVE ELECTIONS
THAT WE SEEK. DR WEBER IS
ABUNDANTLY QUALIFIED TO MEET
THE CHALLENGES OF THE OFFICE OF
SECRETARY OF STATE. BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE HOW
IMPORTANT DISAPPOINTMENT IS TO
SO MANY OF US. DR WEBER WILL BE
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMAN TO BE SECRETARY OF STATE
IN CALIFORNIA. BEING THE FIRST
TO HOLD OFFICE OFTEN COMES WITH
ITS OWN SET OF CHALLENGES BUT
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT
REPRESENTATION MATTERS. WHEN
WOMEN ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF COLOR
ARE ABLE TO SEE THEMSELVES IN
POSITIONS OF POWER IT PROVIDES
OUR POLITICAL SYSTEM WITH
LEGITIMACY. LEGITIMACY IS
SOMETHING THAT IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED DURING THESE TIMES BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT SHOWS US
THAT OUR SYSTEM IS CHANGEABLE.
IT SHOWS US THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO ACCEPT THE WORLD AS IT IS
THAT WE CAN CHANGE THINGS FOR
THE BETTER. WE CAN INSPIRE
OTHER WOMEN. ESPECIALLY WOMEN
OF COLOR TO SEE THEMSELVES AS
THE LEADERS. IT'S NOT ALWAYS
EASY BEIG A TRAILBLAZER DR
WEBER HAS ALWAYS BEEN THAT.
IT'S ALSO SATISFYING WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO UP LIFT EACH
OTHER TO GREATER HEIGHTSWELL
I'M SADDENED WE WILL LOSE SUCH
A PHENOMENAL WOMAN A LEGISLATOR
AND LEADER IN THE ASSEMBLY. I'M
HONORED THE CALIFORNIA WILL GET
AN EXTRAORDINARILY AMAZING
SECRETARY OF STATE WITH DR
WEBBER. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MAJORITY LEADER AS MR FOR. DR
WHATEVER IT'S A THANK YOU CHAIR
BUT IT'S A PRETTY TO SELL THIS
COMMITTEE- ON A HOST DAY AND-
ONE OF THE THINGS IS OUR RANGED
WHEN I GOT A- INTO THIS
POSITION THAT I HOLD NOW. WAS
IT WAS NEVER AWESOME SPEAKING
AFTER YOU. BECAUSE YOUR WORDS-
YOUR PASSION EVEN THOUGH WE MAY
NOT BEEN ON THE SAME SIDE OF AN
ISSUE YOU BROUGHT A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE A PERSPECTIVE THAT
YOU COULD RESPECT YOU COULD
TRUST THAT IT WAS OUT OF A DEEP
EMOTIONAL- COMMITMENT TO THE
COMMUNITY THAT YOU SERVE. I
THINK NOW IN A TIME OF
POLITICAL DYNAMICS THAT WE HAVE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. WE NEED
LEADERS LIKE YOU IN POSITIONS
LIKE THIS. THAT IT'S OKAY TO
DISAGREE IT'S OKAY TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION. BUT WE CAN
ALL STILL BE FRIENDS WE GET ALL
RESPECT EACH OTHER HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE CAN HAVE A
HONEST CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ACROSS GOING ON IN
OUR STATE. WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THIS CREDIBLE COUNTRY THAT WE
LIVE IN SO IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO
BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY AND I
AM. HAPPY TO CONSIDER YOU A
FRIEND AND YOU HAVE BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE A COLLEAGUE OF MINE-
WHETHER YOU KNOW IT OR NOT A
MENTOR. BECAUSE OF HOW YOU
CONDUCTED YOURSELF AND I
APPRECIATE YOU DEARLY SO IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER FLOOR WITH
THAT I THINK WE SHOULD SKIP
STRAIGHT TO THE VOTE. BUT WE
WON'T. AT THIS POINT. WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT PORTION OF THE
AGENDA WE'RE HERE FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S NOMINEE TO BE OUR
NEXT SECRETARY OF STATE- DOCTOR
WEBER. WE LOVE FOR YOU TO JOIN
US- FOR YOUR FOR YOUR REMARKS.
THANK YOU. I ALWAYS MY STUDENTS
TO QUIT WHILE YOU'RE AHEAD. NON
VIOLATING MY OWN SENSE OF-
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR THE
OP TO. BE WITH YOU THIS AND
THIS IS A EXPERIENCE FOR ME BE.
IT BEGINS THE PROCESS OF MIDDLE
YOU AND UP. I WANT TO CRY BUT
TOUGH. AND AN AMAZING AND
ASSEMBLY. IT WAS NOT ON MY LIFE
CHEN TO BE BIGGER TO BE A PART
OF IT. TONI ATKINS TALKED INTO
A THIS MOST KNOW. AND I
WONDERED WHAT WAS FOR ME. YEAH
KNOW WHY WOULD I DO THIS. IN
THE MIDDLE MY RETIREMENT FROM
YOU. THE PUMP AND TO BE IN THE-
BUT I WILL BELIEVED THAT KNOWS
BEST. AND I GENERALLY TRY
FOLLOW THAT PLAN I CAN'T. IT'S
WITH THAT IN MIND I'M I'M HAPPY
TO BE HERE WITH TODAY. AND THIS
TOO WAS AN A PART OF THE PLAN.
BUT IT'S HERE. HELLO THANK YOU
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR BEING
HERE. FOR B. A PART OF THE MY
JOURNEY FOR A YEAR. IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AND AN AMAZING IN
WHICH WE I THINK I BEEN ABLE TO
TOUCH THE LAW. OF SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS. I WILL TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. LOOKING AT ME
IN PICKING OUT HAPPY ME ON THE
SHOULDER WHEN I WAS LOOK. AND
SAY YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS A
YOU. AND ME THINKING VERY HIGH
ABOUT IT I'M TRYING TO DECIDE
IF IS UP I WANTED DO. IT'S
AMAZING TO BE THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN IN THE HUNT AND- YEARS-
TO BE SO. OF STATE. ONLY THE-
AFTER AMERICAN TO BE A HOUSE
OFFICER. AND I'M HUMBLED BY.
COME OUT OF THE BEGINNING OF
THE OF LAW ANGELES. I'M HOME AT
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNE. YOU
COMMITTEE HAVE GIVEN TO THINK
ABOUT IN YOUR DOCTOR AND YOU
HAVE THAT MATTER THINK THAT TO
READ TO YOU. BUT YOU KNOW EVEN
IF WE CAN IN THE MAY ELECT YEAR
AN AMAZING ELECTION YEAR CAL.
UNLIKE ANY OTHER. AND YOU PART
OF THE ACT. BECAUSE I I'VE I'VE
BEEN TO LOOK AT THE BILL'S CAME
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE I WAS ON.
AND EVERY THAT WE HAD TO SUE.
IN THE IN THE IN THE LX
COMMITTEE. EVAN LOW. MARKED
BOTH OF THEM OFFERING CLOSE TO
SIX SEVEN. BILL EACH. AND IF IT
WAS INTERESTING TO ME BUT AS
WITH. RIGHT AT THOSE LAWS THEY-
AND WE HAD NO. HOW SAID. THEY
WOULD. IN THIS AND. WE HAD NO
IDEA THAT WHEN WE WERE OPENING.
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR TO VOTE.
AND FIVE FOR EXCEPT TO VOTE IN
FOR. THOSE ON PAROLE TO VOTE IN
ALL THOSE KIND OF THINGS. WE
DIDN'T WHAT WE WILL BUILD AT
THE TIME BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
FILE. WE GOOD. AND THEY WE
NEEDED TO DO. AND SO THIS
PANDEMIC HIT. THIS STATE THE
LARGEST STATE IN THE WILL
PREPARE. AND YOU ARE THE REASON
WHY IT WAS PER. BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH WE DO DO ALL IN BALLOTS
AT THE BEGINNING WE MADE IN THE
OPTION WE DID SOME PILOTS. AND
ALL THOSE THINGS YOU TO TRY SEE
IF THIS WORK. WE HAD A GOOD FOR.
AND THAT WILL PUT WORKED AND I
WAS HONORED AS I IT COME IN THE
AT PEOPLE IN ME TRACKING MY
VOTE THE SEA WHERE MY BALLOT
CLOSE TO DOUBLE WHAT IF
EVERYBODY WAS GOING TO IT. I
KNEW THAT WHERE IT CAME FROM.
IT CAME FROM THE SCHOOL THIS BY.
THAT REALLY. IN ELECTIONS IN
THE FORWARD. AND SO WE HAD IN A-
EXPERIENCE I CAN REMEMBER WHEN
WE- WERE PUSH WITH THE- INFO.
PER OF A TWO. THAT WE OFTEN
HAVE A BODIES. WE GOT FIFTY.
YEARS COMMUNITIES GOT UP. TO
COMMITTEE. OF BASICALLY SET THE
FOUNDATION. AND WE HAD A GREAT
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH ALEX
IDEA BECAUSE HE'S HE STOPS OF
LAWSUITS AND SOME THINGS THAT.
BLACK PEOPLE'S RIGHTS WOULD
HAVE I WORK WITH HIM IN THE
BEGINNING. AND HE UNDERSTOOD
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND HIS OFFICE AND
HOW WORKING TOGETHER WE CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND WE DID
IT. AND SO I'M REALLY HONORED
THAT THAT WE LOOKED AT THE TURN
OUT. AND WE SAW TREMENDOUS
PROCESS PROGRESS IN THE IN THE
TURN OUT THAT WAS THE YEAR. AND
WILL CONTINUE THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE IT. I KNOW PART OF THE
PART TURNOUT WAS THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE VOTING AGAINST SOMETHING.
AND BODY HARD REPORT- AND
THAT'S A PART OF IT. BUT WE
SHOULD HAVE CRISIS AS THE
FOUNDATION FOR BASICALLY HAVING
TURNED OUT. AND I'M HOPING THAT
THROUGH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE WE CAN BEGIN TO
TALK ABOUT CIVIC EDUCATION.
CIVIC RESPONSIBILITY. TO HELP
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND IF NOT
WE'LL TO PEOPLE AS WELL
UNDERSTAND. WHAT DEMOCRACY IS.
HOW FRAGILE IT IS. AND HOW WE
HAVE TO PUT WORK TO MAINTAIN
IT. AND THAT VOTING AS THE
CENTRAL TO GET THAT TO HAPPEN.
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT ALREADY
LOOKING AT WORKING WITH OUR
SCHOOLS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENS
AROUND THE WORLD. WHEN PEOPLE
FAIL TO SHOW UP TO VOTE. AND
HOW PRECIOUS IT IS. AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS IN THIS
DEMOCRACY. TO MAINTAIN THAT. SO
WE DON'T WORK ON THOSE KINDS OF
ISSUES BUT WE SET THE
FOUNDATION AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK THAT FOUNDATIONS MAKE
IT HAPPEN. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
OUR BUSINESSES AND WORKING WITH
A BUSINESSES AND THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. I WHEN I
WAS IN AND SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE WE HAVE ALMOST DIGITIZED
ALMOST EVERYTHING COMPUTERIZED
EVERYTHING. THAT WE HAVE EXCEPT
FOR A LITTLE BIT THAT'S LEFT.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN OUR BUSINESSES IN
THIS PANDEMIC FLOUNDER. AND NOT
HAVE THE KIND OF SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEEDED TO GROW. WE SEE NO
NONPROFITS DO THE SAME THING.
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
PROCESS IT'S CLEAR. THAT IT'S
HELPFUL THAT IT SUPPORTED THAT
WE HAVE FOLKS WHO COULD HELP
THE TO DO THAT. BECAUSE SO FOR
SO MANY COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY SMALL BUSINESSES
IS ALL THEY HAVE. FOR SO MANY
FAMILIES THAT'S ALL THEY HAVE.
AND SO WILL BEGIN TO WALK AWAY
FROM THAT IT BECOMES DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO SURVIVE. NOT ONLY
JUST FINANCIALLY BUT
EMOTIONALLY AND PERSONALLY. I
TO INVEST IN WE HAVE IN SOME
COMMUNITIES THIRTY AND FORTY
YEARS. OF RESTAURANTS IN SOME
ETHNIC COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE TO
FOLD. IN THE THAT THAT IS THAT
IS DEVASTATING TO A LEGACY OF
FAMILY. THAT IS STRUGGLE SO
HARD TO KEEP THOSE THINGS OPEN
AND SO WE HAVE A REALLY BIG
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE.
THAT OUR PROCESS IS CLEAR THAT
IT'S HELPFUL. AND WE CAN FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO WORK WITH OTHER
ENTITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE. ONCE AGAIN
TRYING TO GET THE LICENSE BACK
TRYING TO OPEN THE BUSINESSES.
THAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE IS THERE FOR THEM AS
WELL THE LARGE BUSINESSES WELL
AS A SMALL. AND PARTICULARLY
OUR NON PROFITS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING PARTICULARLY NON%
PROFITS THAT ARE NOT LARGE
NONPROFITS. IF YOU'RE A POOR
COMMUNITY YOU HAVE LOTS OF NON
PROFITS. YOU HAVE LOTS OF
SOCIAL ORGANIZATIONS AND CLUBS
AND MASONS AND ALL THOSE
PEOPLE. WHO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
HELP FOR THOSE WHO ARE. DYING
FOR THOSE WHO APPEAL. AND MANY
OF OUR NONPROFITS WE HAD A TOWN
HALL WHICH WAS STRUGGLING TO
SURVIVE. IS WILLING TO WORK ON
THOSE THINGS A LITTLE WORK ON.
ISSUES OF CYBERSECURITY REMAINS
ALWAYS A MAJOR ISSUE THAT
SHOULD NEVER EVER OVERCOME. AND
YOU NEVER FINISHED. AND SO WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TO PROTECT
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
FEEL CONFIDENCE IN THE BIZ IN
IN WHAT WE'RE DOING. IN OUR
OFFICES SO THAT THERE IS NO
QUESTION ABOUT THE SECURITY OF
IT. AND WHEN THERE ARE
QUESTIONS WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE HONEST. TO
BE OPEN. AND BE QUICK ABOUT SO
ALL THE- AND NOT PUT. THAT IT'S-
WE WANT HIDE BECAUSE IT NEVER.
DID A GROWS IN TIME. LET ME
JUST I KNOW THERE'S A CAN ABOUT.
IN THE CONTRACT THAT WAS GIVEN
AN- I I'VE TOLD SOMEONE THE
OTHER DAY I SIT DOWN THERE'S A
BET BENNETT TO DISADVANTAGE OF
BEING MARRIED TO A LAWYER FOR
TWENTY NINE YEARS. IS THAT HE
ALWAYS HAD A FREE PRETTY MUCH
FOR YOU SURELY DON'T GIVE LEGAL
ADVICE HE SAID BECAUSE YOU
DON'T PRACTICE LAW WITHOUT A
LICENSE THAT'S NUMBER ONE. AND
HE SAID NUMBER TWO IF YOU
COMMENT ON THE CASE BEFORE
THAT'S THAT'S BEING LITIGATED
YOU NOW BECOME THE SUBJECT OF
THE CASE. AND SO UNLESS YOU
WANT TO BE A PARTY. TO THE
LAWSUIT. DON'T SAY ANYTHING.
JUST BASICALLY SAY YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. BUT I CAN'T
SAY THAT I'VE LOOKED AT IT. I
LOOK AT IT FROM BOTH SIDES-
I'VE TALKED WITH NOT ONLY ALL
THE SECRETARY STATE FORM SECTOR
STATE. AND THE CONTROLLER. AND
I'VE LEARNED SOME THINGS ABOUT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO DIFFERENTLY.
THE TRADITION IS NOT A WAY TO
DO BUSINESS. BUT THE LOSS THE
WAY TO DO BUSINESS. AND WILL
MAKE SURE THAT WE HANDLE THOSE
ISSUES AND ADDRESS THEM
APPROPRIATELY IN MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT WORKS NOW. BUT
AS WE GO FORWARD IT MIGHT MIGHT
ISSUES. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE DO IS WE GO FORWARD.
AND AS WE GO FORWARD WE WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS. U. S. A
LOT OF QUESTIONS YOU DIDN'T ASK
MUCH ABOUT ARCHIVES. BECAUSE I
GUESS YOU FIGURE THAT'S A
PRETTY SECURE- AND THAT'S AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT PART OF
WHAT WE DO. SO AND YOU KNOW AS
I WAS THOUGHT ABOUT ALL THOSE
THINGS I SAID I HAVE ANSWERED
THE QUESTIONS. AND I COULD
PROBABLY GIVE YOU MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT EACH ONE OF
THOSE AS WE HAVE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE ASKED. BUT. I THINK WHAT
THE REAL QUESTION IS WHO IS-
WHO IS THIS ONE OF THE YOU WANT
AND- THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE TO. WHAT SHE MADE UP
WHAT SHE BELIEVED BECAUSE IN
THE END THAT'S WHAT REALLY
MATTERS. THAT'S WHAT WILL
DECIDE THE DECISIONS THAT I
MAKE AND HOW ARE WORK WITH YOU
IN THE IN IN GOING FORWARD. YOU
KNOW THOSE THINGS THAT A CORE
VALUE TO ME. MOST OF YOU READ
MY RESUME AT SOME POINT IN YOUR
LIFE AND YOU DISCOVERED THAT I
HAVE A- FEW DEGREES FROM UCLA.
ABOUT TIME A TWENTY SIX OF THE
UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR TWENTY
THREE BLAH BLAH BLAH BLAH BLAH.
IN MY YEARS OF ADMINISTRATION
AND MY WORK AT THE UNIVERSITY
AND MY WORK IN THE COMMUNITY.
WHAT YOU MAY NOT KNOW IS THAT
I'M THE DAUGHTER OF
SHARECROPPERS. AND THIS IS AN
AWFUL LOT ABOUT MY LIFE. MY
FATHER WAS A SHARECROPPER HIS
FATHER WAS A SHARECROPPER IN
HOPE ARKANSAS. AND THEY LIVED
IN A LIFE THAT WAS VERY SIMILAR
VERY LIMITED AND VERY SMALL.
BUT MY DAD WAS PROBABLY ALWAYS
PROBLEM. AND ALWAYS FOUGHT BACK
FOR WHAT WAS RIGHT MOVES JUST.
AND IN THE PROCESS OF THAT HE
ALMOST LOST HIS LIFE. SO IF
LEVEL ARKANSAS WHEN I WAS JUST
THIS THE BABY OF THE FAMILY.
AND LEVELS THERE. AND CAME TO
CALIFORNIA WITH MY MOTHER'S
MOTHER LIP. BECAUSE THEY WILL
WANT TO LYNCH HIM IN HOPE
ARKANSAS. AND SO WE CAME IN
CALIFORNIA BUT HE HAD CAME WITH
A LOT OF BELIEF AND A LOT OF
STRENGTH ABOUT WHAT HE WANTED
TO FORCE FAMILY. AND IN THREE
MONTHS HE WORKED AND EARNED
ENOUGH TO PUT US ALL ON THE
TRAIN THAT WAS SIX CHILDREN
INTO IT MY MOTHER. ON A TRAIN
COMING TO CALIFORNIA TO LIVE
AND TO CREATE A LIFE. I LIVED
IN THE PUEBLOS THE PROJECTS OF
LOSS AND IS WHO FIRST BUILT.
WINDOWS SEVEN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. LIMITED RESOURCES. WE
HAD A FAMILY THAT WAS RICH IN
TRADITION AND RICH IN VALUES
THE REGION LOW. AND SO I GOT MY
FAMILY OF MY FAMILY SHARE
CROPPERS. BUT MY DAD BELIEVED
WHAT THEY TWO THINGS ONE I
BELIEVE IN EDUCATION. THE
SECOND THING YOU BELIEVE IN
VOTING. SO WHEN I BEGAN TO LOOK
AT THIS POSITION OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. I SAID HOW
I FIT INTO THIS PICTURE YOU
KNOW WHAT MY VALUES IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN HERE. AND I
REALIZE THAT ALL OF MY LIFE WE
HAVE WE HAD THE VALUE LOADING
IN MY FAMILY. NOT JUST GOING TO
THE POLLS. BUT WE HAD ACTUALLY
A POLL IN OUR HOUSE. MY LIVING
ROOM WAS THE PROOF WAS A VOTING
POLL VOTING PRECINCTS. AND THE
ADDRESS OF THREE FIFTY ONE WEST
FORTY FIFTH STREET PUBLISHED
TWENTY YEARS. IN LOS ANGELES
WAS A VOTING POLL. MY MOTHER MY
FATHER OPEN OUR HOME TO VOTING
BECAUSE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL COULD
NO LONGER ACCOMMODATE. THE
VOTING ADVOCATE BECAUSE OF
LUNCH AND BREAKFAST BEING GIVEN
IN THE SCHOOL. WE HAD NO
LIBRARY CLOSED LAST WE HAD NO
REC CENTER. SO THE ONLY PLACE
WE HAD WAS SOMEONE TOLD. AND MY
FATHER SAID VOTING IS TO IMPORT
TO PUT IN THE GARAGE. SO I
REMOVED THE FURNITURE AT EVERY
ELECTION. AND PEOPLE VOTED IN
OUR LIVING ROOM. SO I GREW UP
WITH LOOKING AT PEOPLE VOTE
EVERY DAY. AND KNOWING THAT IT
WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IN
THE WORLD MY DAD SAID YOU COULD
DO BECAUSE HE NEVER GOT A
CHANCE TO VOTE IN HOPE
ARKANSAS. AND HIS DAD AND HIS
MOM NEVER GOT A CHANCE TO GO IN
THAT ENTIRE LIFE. BECAUSE THEY
DIED BEFORE NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE.
AND SO WHEN I LOOK AT IT I SAY
YOU KNOW I HAVE A PASSION ABOUT
VOTING. I DEMAND THAT ALL MY
CHILDREN BOTH MY NIECE MY
NEPHEW BECAUSE EVERYBODY IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD- WHEN I WAS A
STUDENT I WOULD AS A PROFESSOR
THE UNIVERSITY IF YOU RUN OUT
OF MY CLASS AND ELECTION YOU
HAVE TO SHOW ME THE TAG TO GET
REGISTERED TO VOTE. IN ORDER TO
REMAIN IN MY CLASS. BECAUSE YOU
COULD NOT BE AN INTELLIGENT
PERSON AND NOT BUILT. AND SO AS
A RESULT THAT WAS EVERY STUDENT
KNEW THAT THEY HAD TO EITHER
REGISTER TO VOTE IF THEY WERE.
EIGHTEEN OVER. WHAT THEY HAD TO
HELP SOMEBODY ELSE REGISTER TO
VOTE AND BRING ME THAT. THEIR
DOCUMENTATION THAT THEY HIT.
BECAUSE I WANTED THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT'S A PART OF
BEING AN AMERICAN. BEING ABLE
TO VOTE. I'M ALSO PROUD.
BELIEVER STRONGLY IN
BUSINESSES. BECAUSE I LOOK AT
IT NOT JUST AS THE NUMBER
BUSINESSES WE HAVE IN THE
LARGER SENSE. BUT I LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT MY DAD WORKED EVERY
DAY. IN A FACTORY. AND FOR
THIRTY TWO YEARS HE DROVE BY.
FROM FROM LOS ANGELES TO. BUT
NOT DOWNTOWN LA ALL THE WAY TO
COMMERCE. AND HE SAW THE NUMBER
OF BLACK A BUSINESSES GOING OUT
OF BUSINESS. EVERY YEAR. HE
WATCHED THE FIRESTONE'S IN THE
GOOD YEARS. AND THE BETHLEHEM
STEEL'S. LEAVE OP OUR
COMMUNITY. GOOD JOB THAT HE
WORKED IN A STEEL MILL HIMSELF.
AND HE SAW THE STRONG JOBS
LEAVING IN EVERY YEAR HE TALKED
ABOUT HOW THEY WERE GOING AWAY.
SO THAT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE WHEN HE RETIRED. IN IN
MARCH OF NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
IN JUNE OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE HIS FACTORY SHUT DOWN. HE
MISSED ABOUT TWO MONTHS. AND SO
HE I KNEW THAT WHEN AND WHAT
I'VE WITH A BUSINESS LEAVES
IT'S NOT JUST THE BOTTOM LINE
FOR CALIFORNIA. IT IS THE
BOTTOM LINE FOR PEOPLE. THE
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND FAMILIES ARE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE
BUSINESSES THAT WE HAVE IN THE
BUSINESS AND THE ABILITY OF
THOSE GOOD BUSINESSES TO
PROVIDE STABILITY FOR FAMILIES
AND FOR THEM TO GROW. AND SO
WHEN I THINK THE BUSINESS I NOT
ONLY THINK ABOUT LARGE NUMBERS.
I THINK IT WAS SMALL BUSINESSES
THE BEAUTY SHOPS THAT THE
BARBER SHOPS. THE RESTAURANTS
YOU KNOW THE REAL ESTATE
COMPANIES THOSE THINGS IN MY
FAMILY HAVE OWNED FOR YEARS IN
TERMS OF WORKING AS
PHOTOGRAPHERS AND OTHERS THEY
THOSE OF BUSINESSES THAT. HELP
FAMILIES TO GROW AND TO DEVELOP
AND GET TRIED TO FAMILIES AND
PEOPLE. IN THE COMMUNITY SO I'M
TO UNDERSTAND BUSINESS BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THE BOTTOM LINE. IS ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY IT. AND I CAN TELL
YOU YOUR LIFE CHANGES WHEN YOUR
WHEN YOUR FATHER'S FACTORY
SHUTS DOWN. WHEN THEY GO ON
WHEN THEY GO ON ALL A WHEN THEY
LAID OFF. OF WHEN THEY'RE ON
STRIKE. THE WHOLE WORLD STOP
FOR YOU BECAUSE OF THE CHILD IT
STOPPED FOR ME. AND SO I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
BUSINESSES THERE. I UNDERSTAND
THE POINT FOR NONPROFITS IN OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE ARE MOST.
COMMUNITY CENTER FOR OUR FIELD
NONPROFITS. EVERYBODY WAS A
GOOD IDEA STOCKTON NONPROFIT.
YOU KNOW THEY WANT TO HELP
THEIR NEIGHBORS THEY WANT TO
HELP THEIR COMMUNITY. AND THEY
NEED THE SUPPORT NOT ONLY TO
START THE NONPROFIT BUT HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SUSTAIN IT.
IN THESE DIFFICULT TIMES. WHEN
THE PANDEMIC WE OPEN UP THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF SAN DIEGO HAS A NONPROFIT
ENTITY TO BEGIN TO EDUCATE MY
COMMUNITY. ABOUT WHAT IT WAS TO
HAVE A NONPROFIT. AND HOW TO
WORK THAT NONPROFIT. OUR
SECRETARY STATE NEEDS TO DO
MORE THAN JUST REGISTERED
NONPROFITS WE NEED TO HELP THEM
FIGURE OUT HOW TO FILE THE
PAPERS THEY NEED TO HELP THEM.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE
SUCCESSFUL NOT JUST THE
THROTTLE TO SURVIVE BUT TO
THRIVE IN IN THE ENVIRONMENT OF
NONPROFITS. AND LASTLY OUR
ARCHIVES THERE ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND I LOOKED AT. THIS
WHOLE JOB OF SECRETARY OF STATE.
FOR MY LIFE I'VE BEEN A-
WORKING TO. SHE HISTORY YOUNG.
OF NOT ONLY IN. BUT- THE WORLD.
BUT I ALSO REALIZE THAT ALL OF
MY LIFE I HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
FIND MY PAST. A PAST THAT HAD
BEEN STOLEN FROM AFRICAN
AMERICANS. THERE WERE FOR EVER
LOOKING TO FIGURE OUT WHO ARE
GREAT GREAT GRANDFATHER WAS IN
OUR GREAT GREAT GRANDMOTHER WAS
IT. GO AND COMING THROUGH THE
ARCHIVES. BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT HAVING INFORMATION BUT
BASICALLY ABOUT SPREADING THAT
INFORMATION. AND HELPING PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND. IF WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT CIVIC EDUCATION AND
HELPING PEOPLE APPRECIATE WHAT
WE HAVE. WE HAVE TO TEACH THEM
WHAT IT IS. WE HAVE TO OPEN OUR
ARCHIVES. AND SO AS I TALK WITH
OUR ARCHIVES DIRECTOR WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT. CREATING THE
OPPORTUNITY BUT NOT JUST FOR
THOSE WHO RESEARCHES TO DEAL
COMING TO OUR TAX. BUT THOSE
WERE CITIZENS. UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S IN THE ARCHIVES AND TO
SHARE THEIR MATERIAL AND PUT
THEM IN OUR TAX AND MAKE THOSE
ARCHIVES AVAILABLE TO OUR
LIBRARIES. AROUND THE STATE SO
PEOPLE SO WE CAN REALLY FIGURE
OUT WHAT CALIFORNIA IS ALL
ABOUT. BECAUSE THAT INFORMATION
WILL HELP US TO GET BEYOND SOME
OF THE HATRED THAT WE FEEL.
SOME OF THE DIFFICULTIES THAT
WE FACE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
THE CHALLENGES WE WILL CONTINUE
TO FACE. IT IS INTERESTING AS I
LOOKED AT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S POSITION. AND TRY TO
COMPARE MYSELF TO AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO WORK WITH OPINION. I
REALIZE IT IS MOST THINGS MOST
OF MY LIFE HAS BEEN IN
PREPARATION FOR TO BE SECRETARY
OF STATE. THAT THE THINGS I
HAVE DONE NOT ONLY IN MY JUST
GENERAL BELIEF ABOUT VOTING AND
THE LEGISLATION HAS BEEN HERE.
BUT MY EFFORTS TO WORK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY RESOURCE THAT WE HAD WAS
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE. THAT THE
INTERCONNECTION BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE HATRED THAT'S IN THIS
COUNTRY. BUT MOST OF US LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENED A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO WE LOOK AT WILL TRUMAN THE
SADNESS. TREMENDOUS SADNESS
BECAUSE WE THOUGHT WE WERE MUCH
FURTHER ALONG THAN WE WERE. BUT
WE ALSO HAVE TO REALIZE THAT WE
ARE PROBABLY BETTER OFF THAN WE
WERE BEFORE. BUT THIS IS. WHAT
HAPPENED IN TWO WEEKS AGO AS A
REMINDER OF US TO ALL OF US.
THAT WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITY TO KEEP TO BE
VIGILANT ABOUT THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT. THAT WE
COULD NOT TURN OUR BACK ON.
THAT IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SECURING A VOTE SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CREATING
OPPORTUNITY IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. OUR CAT BEGIN
UNDERSTANDING OUR HISTORY IN
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS A CONSTANT
JOB. THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WORK AT EVERY DAY. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE ME A CHANCE ONCE AGAIN. TO
EDUCATE CALIFORNIANS. ABOUT
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
DUCATION IS MUSCLE MY PASSION.
AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THOSE
WHO KNOW BETTER WOULD DO
BETTER. AND SO I THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY I THINK THE
GOVERNOR FORD I THINK MY STAFF
THAT'S HELPED SO MUCH IN THE
LAST. FEW WEEKS OF TRANSITION
IT HAS BEEN LIKE DRINKING WATER
FROM A- FIRE HOSE OF COURSE.
BUT I THANK YOU FOR BEING MY
COLLEAGUES WILL BE MY FRIEND.
FOR HELPING ME TO. FIGURE OUT A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND TO FIGURE OUT
HOW I CAN. OBVIOUSLY SERVE AND
SERVE BETTER. AND MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE PLACE OF MY
FATHER DREAMED ABOUT. MANY
YEARS AGO WHEN HE BROUGHT HIS
FAMILY TO CALIFORNIA. A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY. FOR ALL OF US.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- DOCTOR.
AND AS MR FLOOR ALLUDED TO- I
PITY THE PEOPLE TO GO AFTER YOU-
BUT FOR THE NEXT PORTION OF OUR
AGENDA WE'LL BE HEARING FROM
REPRESENTATIVES OF THREE
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS. THAT
WORK WITHIN OF BUSINESSES ARE
THE AND HAVE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE. THE FIRST PERSON THAT
WE WILL HEAR FROM IS TRICIA
WEBER WHO IS THE SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY CLERK. AND WHO IS
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS-
AND MS WEBBER THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AND I ASSUME. OUR
TECH TEAM HAS EVERYTHING TEED
UP. PERFECT. I THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN OF BERMAN AND THANK
YOU FOR PROVIDING A SAFE WAY
FOR ME TO PARTICIPATE THIS
AFTERNOON. CHAIR BERMAN CHAIR
LOW AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TRICIA WEBER AND I AM HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CA CEO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
AND ASSOCIATION COMPRISED OF
CALIFORNIANS. FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY CLERK'S REGISTERED
VOTERS AND CLERK OF THE BOARD'S.
F. COUNTY CLERK'S REGISTRAR
VOTERS WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE. COUNTY CLERK'S WORK
WITH THE SOS WHEN REGISTERING
NOTARY FILINGS THAT SYSTEM WITH
THE OPPOSITE YOUR PROCESS AND
WE REGULARLY CONSULT THE
BUSINESS PROGRAMS EIGHT ARE
COUNTY RESIDENTS WHEN FILING
THEIR BUSINESS NAMES. EQUALLY
IMPORTANT TO REGISTER VOTERS
WORKS HAND IN HAND WITH THE SOS
WHEN CONDUCTING ALL ELECTIONS
WE'VE ENJOYED A WONDERFUL
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH
PREVIOUS SECRETARIES TO PUT
TOGETHER GUIDANCE COVER
VERSIONS REGULATIONS BEST
PRACTICES AND MOST RECENTLY THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION.
HOW DOES THE U. CEO ALLEGE
ELECTIONS LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
CO CHAIR I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF WORKING WITH DR WEBBER IN
HER ROLE ON THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. I FOUNDER
TO BE KNOWLEDGEABLE ALEXION
LIES AND UNDERSTANDING THE
WORKING ASPECTS OF CONDUCTING
AN ELECTION AND VERY PLEASANT
TO WORK WITH. WHEN DISCUSSING
DR WEBER PROPOSED BUT OPPOSED
LEGISLATION DIRECTLY WITH HER
OR HER STAFF I FOUND THE
CONVERSATIONS TO BE
INFORMATIVE. AMICABLE AND THAT
WE MAY NOT ALWAYS HAVE AGREED
I'VE ALWAYS LEFT THE
INTERACTION WITH THE FEELING
THAT I WAS HURT MY OPINION WAS
UNDERSTOOD. AND MY POSITION
RESPECTED. I BELIEVE THAT WHAT
WE HAVE AN X. ONE I HAVE THE-
IN THE PAST WILL CONTINUE WITH
DOCTOR WEBBER ASKED SECRETARY
OF STATE. I BELIEVE THAT SHE
AND HER STAFF WILL CONTINUE
THAT TYPE OF RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE COUNTY CLERK'S AND THE
REGISTRAR'S. I BELIEVE THAT SHE
WILL INVITE THE COUNTIES TO
DISCUSS THE FUTURE OF ELECTIONS
AND WILL LISTEN UNDERSTAND AND
RESPOND WITH THE REGISTRARS
HAVE TO SAY. I BELIEVE SHE WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE THE BUSINESS
PROGRAMS HOUSED AT THE SLS
BUILDING BETTER EACH YEAR
SOLICITING INPUT FROM THE END
USERS WHICH IS COMPRISED OF
BOTH INDIVIDUALS AND COUNTY. I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH DR
WEBBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
WEBER NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
ROBERT LAPSLEY WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE. LASTLY
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. CHAIRMAN ARE CARILLO
KAREN BERMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY. ABSOLUTELY
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE. YOU KNOW
ABBOTT HALF OF LARGE MEDIUM AND
SMALL EMPLOYERS I'M TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE
BOARD DIRECTORS I CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW PLEASED WE ARE TO BE
APPROVED FOR. THISNOMINATION
TODAY FOR SOME CHARLIE WEBER DR
WEBER AS OUR NEXT SECRETARY OF
STATE. YOU HEARING STOCK RUBBER
STATEMENT TODAY ACTUALLY SAYS
IT ALL I AND WE DEFINITELY
THINK. REFERRAL OUTGOING
COMMENTS TODAY ON JOBS. HOUSE
TWO MAJOR DOT WEBER HAS
UNPARALLELED MARC. AWFUL
CONSENSUS BUILDER OR RESPECT
SENDING. ALL STAKEHOLDER IN THE
DAHLE PUB POLICY SOLUTIONS YOU
KNOW WHEN NEED CALIFORNIA
ROUNDTABLE SPENT THIS PAST YEAR
WORKING WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY CALIFORNIA'S
STATEWIDE GROUPS INCLUDING
PLANNED THE FIRST PERSON THAT
WE TURNED TO WAS DOCTOR WEBER.
WE ASK FOR HER INPUT ON REFORMS
THAT COULD HELP THIS BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND SHE GRACIOUSLY
WORK WITH US ON A PLAN THAT WAS
ULTIMATELY ADOPTED BY MIKE WARD
AND NOW WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH BUSINESS. ARE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. NO A PERSONAL NOTE.
I WOULD PREVIOUS HAD THE OF
SERVING AS- OF STATE IN THE
OFFICE. I WONDER SECRETARY BILL
JONES AND I WAS THERE FOR
ALMOST YEARS. BY MANY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE HAVE TAUGHT ME THAT
THE ROLE OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE THE VERY FACT JUST A VERY
SPECIAL ONE. BUT SHE OVERSEEING
THE FUNDAMENTAL CORNERSTONES OF
OUR DEMOCRACY WHICH IS
ADMINISTRATION OF A FREE AND
FAIR ELECTION YEAH THE
TRANSPARENCY OF OUR CAMPAIGN
FINANCE SYSTEM. SO NO ONE
SHARES THOSE IDEALS MORE THAN
AND OR IS MORE COMMITTED TO
THOSE GOALS DR WORK. SO LASTLY
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT THE
OTHER CORNERSTONES OF THAT
OFFICE FOR DOING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA FROM THE STATE
BUSINESS FILINGS NOTARY PUBLICS
TO UCC FILING SYSTEMS AND OTHER
STATEWIDE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
LOOKS FORWARD TO SUPPORTING DR
WEBER OUR STAFF. AND ALL THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES. ON BEHALF OF.
ALL EMPLOYERS CALIFORNIA SO WE
COMMENDED GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
NOMINATING DR WEBER WE FULLY
SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION IS
BEST QUALIFIED CANDIDATES BE
CALIFORNIA'S NEXT SECRETARY OF
STATE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATEWIDE BUSINESS COMMUNITY WE
CAN'T CONGRATULATE HER. ON HER
WELL DESERVED NOMINATION. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER. ALL CAPACITIES IN HER NEW
ROLE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MR LAPSLEY.
FINALLY WE'LL HEAR FROM MERRY
CHRISTMAS THE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND
MISTREATMENT- PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BERMAN
CHAIRMAN ALLOW THE COMMITTEE WE
ARE SO EXCITED TO BE HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THIS CONVERSATION
AND THE OPPORTUNITY CALIFORNIA
HAS. I'M YOU KNOW WE THINK
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESSIVE
LEADERSHIP NATIONWIDE AND WHAT
MORE WE HAVE TO DO AND NONE OF
THAT IS GOING TO BE POSSIBLE
UNTIL WEHAVE A FULL AND
PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY. AND IS
ALREADY HAS BEEN MENTIONED
TODAY REPRESENTATION MATTERS
AND IT MATTERS MOST IN POLICY
MAKING AND MOST WORK LIKE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S WORK OUT
WE WILL HAVE OUR FIRST BLACK
WOMAN IN THIS ROLE. AND THE
POWER AND WHAT THAT MEANS CAN'T
BE UNDERSTATED WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT BLACK COMMUNITIES WE
THINK ABOUT WOMEN. THESE ARE
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
SYSTEMICALLY DISENFRANCHISE
FROM POLITICAL POWER. AND THE
RESULTS OF THAT ARE BEING FELT
ACROSS OUR STATE AND ACROSS OUR
NATION AND IT IS GOING TO TAKE
EXPLICIT. IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
ELECTORAL SYSTEM EXPLICIT
EDUCATION EXPLICIT BREAKING
DOWN OF BARRIERS EXPLODE SAY
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE. TO
OVERCOME THAT AND TO CORRECT
THESE INJUSTICES. AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT DR WEBER HAS A
BODY YOU'VE HEARD FROM HER AND
I FEEL LIKE I'M JUST PILING ON
AT THIS MOMENT BUT I'M HAPPY TO
DO SO. DID SHE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING IN CHAMPION
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS. AND DEMOCRACY
IT'S ABSOLUTELY A CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE ABSOLUTELY IT IS. WE HAVE
DONE SO MUCH AND MADE SO MUCH
PROGRESS UNDER BOTH SENATOR
BEEN D. ACT AND A FEW FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE BUT WE STILL
HAVE SO MUCH TO DO. VOTER
REGISTRATION IN ITSELF IS A
HURDLE FOR COMMUNITIES IT'S A
BEAR HERE FOR POLITICAL VOICE
WE THINK ABOUT ELIGIBLE VOTERS
REGISTEREDREGISTERED VOTERS WE
THINK ABOUT ALL THE WAYS THAT
FOLKS. NEED TO BOTH UNDERSTAND
AND FEEL CONNECTED AND FEEL
LIKE THEIR VOICE MATTERS. AND
DR WEBBER IS EXACTLY THE LEADER
WITH THE VISION FOR HOW TO
TRANSFORM PEOPLE'S RELATIONSHIP
WITH GOVERNMENT AND THAT STARTS
WITH TRANSFORMING PEOPLE'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH VOTING. SHE
HAS LEAD ON THESE ISSUES FROM
PREPAID POSTAGE FROM VOTE BY
MAIL TO THE DISCLOSE ACT WHICH
GIVE ALL VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRULY KNOW WHO IS FINDING
CAMPAIGN MESSAGES. TO AUTOMATIC
VOTER REGISTRATION ACA SIX
WHICH JUST PASSED WE IN
FRANCHISING PEOPLE ON PAROLE IN
THE VOTING SYSTEM AND SHE'S
OFFERED LEGISLATION TO MANDATE
THAT PEOPLE COMING OUT OF JAIL%
OR PRISON NO THEIR VOTING
RIGHTS AT THAT TIME. SHE HAS A
LONG HISTORY NOT JUST OF
LEANING ON ELECTION LEADING ON
INTEGRATED INTO INTERSEX
STRATEGIES. TO ADVANCE JUSTICE
AND EQUITY OUR VOTING SYSTEM
AND OUR ELECTORAL SYSTEM IS AT
THE CENTER. OF WE WILL NOT GET
FROM IT'S A POLICIES WE NOT
MOVE. WHETHER IT YOU BALLOT
INITIATIVE. OR THE LEAD. OR
FULLY. LEADERS IN SAKHIR AND-
IN LAST WE HAVE A FULL AND
EQUITABLE VOTING SYSTEM AND
THAT'S WHY I AM SO EXCITED TO
INCREASE WORD WITH THIS
NOMINATION I'M FOR CALIFORNIA
TO LIVE OUR VALUES NEED A
LEADER LIKE DR SHIRLEY WEBER.
LEADING THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
CHRISTMANN. IF THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
ARE SORRY THIS CONCLUDES THE
ORGANIZATIONAL PERSPECTIVES
PORTION OF OUR AGENDA. SO THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS
PUBLIC COMMENT. IF THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN TESTIFYING IN
REGARDS TO DOCTOR WAS
NOMINATION TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. PLEASE CALL AND NOW IF
YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE SO
AND AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC
CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO- TO. BEFORE
YOU GO TO THE PHONES ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. IF SO PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. SEEING NONE.
OH I'M SORRY- OKAY OF A COUPLE
PLEASE- I WOULD TOO QUICKLY-
COME ON UP- AND WE HAVE A
MICROPHONE RIGHT OVER HERE.
THIS MAY JUST COME ONE AT A
TIME WOULD BE GREAT MY
APOLOGIES. MY GLASSES GET
FOGGED UP. SO WHEN WE SAY- WILL
HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES PER
SPEAKER. I'LL BE VERY GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
DONNA WOULD I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF
NEGRO WOMEN SACRAMENTO VALLEY
SECTION AND ALSO THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. BUT I SPEAK TODAY
ON BEHALF OF ALL SECTIONS FOR
BOTH NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND A DOZEN OR MORE
COLLEGIATE SECTIONS WE BELIEVE
AND WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
THE NOMINATION AND EVENTUALLY
THE APPOINTMENT OF DR SHIRLEY
WEBER AS CALIFORNIA'S NEXT
SECRETARY OF STATE
CONGRADULATIONS DR WEBER. ON
YOUR NOMINATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BETTY WILLIAMS I'M THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO NAACP PRESIDENT AS
WELL AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA HAWAII NAACP
STATE CONFERENCE I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF OUR NEW PRESIDENT
RICK CALENDAR WHO ALSO WISHES
DR WEBER AND CONGRATULATE YOU
ON YOUR NEW POSITION- IT WAS
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO YOU SWORE
ME IN- THE NAACP AND I AM SO
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. I STAND
BEFORE YOU AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE NAACP WHEN OUR VALUES
STAND ON THE RIGHTS OF VOTING.
AND TO BE HERE PART OF HISTORY.
TO HAVE THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN PRESENT THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEING
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE I AM SO
HUMBLED AND I AM SO PROUD. TO
BE HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
N. A. A. C. P. YOU HAVE TO KNOW
AS A BLACK WOMAN THE PRIDE I
FEEL RIGHT NOW. WE DO SUPPORT
THE NOMINATION OF THE SECRETARY
OF STATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HAWAII NAACP AND
CONGRADULATIONS DR WEBER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO DOCTOR
WEBER AND CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DR COURT PORTER AND I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERSHIP
LOCALLY AND THROUGHOUT.
CALIFORNIA WELL WE ARE HAPPY
AND EXCITED TO SUPPORT THE
NOMINATION AND SOON TO BE
CONFIRMATION OF DR SHIRLEY
WEBER AS OUR NEXT SECRETARY OF
STATE. AND THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN IN THIS
POSITION. WE ARE MORE THAN
CONFIDENT THAT SHE WILL SERVE
THE CITIENS OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE SAME MANNER OF EXCELLENCE
YES YES SERVED IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN
TALK ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS
IN THE ROOM. THE PHONE NOT THE
PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING THE
NOMINATION OF DR WEBER THREE
CALIFORNIA'S NEXT SECRETARY OF
STATE MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY. WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT AFTERNOON
SURE BERMAN HELLO MEMBERS AND
DR WEBBER W. ON BEHALF OF THE
W. NAY LOCAL THIRTY NINE HE
REPRESENT A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND HOME CARE TACTICAL
FIGHTER STATEWIDE. DOCTOR WEBER
HOW CAN A LONGSTANDING CHAMPION
FOR PROVIDERS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES CHAPTER SEVEN
TREATED THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE TO GIVE EVERY
CALIFORNIANS THE RIGHT TO LIVE
IN A FAIR AND JUST SOCIETY.
FREE OF DISCRIMINATION AND
POVERTY- FOR ETHIC AND ONLY
BRING THAT MAKE THE STATE
HEALTH. PROVIDER WITH NOTHING
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE TO
LEAD CALIFORNIA AFTER SECRETARY
OF STATE. WE ARE TRULY HONORED
TO SUPPORT DOCTOR WHETHER A
DOOR CALL. OINTMENT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK. WE DO OF
A COMMENT FROM LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S JACKIE GRAY
WHILE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
A YEAR HE W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL I'M HONORED TO TESTIFY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
CONFIRMATION OF DR BARBARA
CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF STATE.
AS AMERICA CONTINUES ON THE
LONG JOURNEY TOWARD A MORE
PERFECT UNION CALIFORNIA STANDS
OUT AS A STRONG AS ADVOCATING
CONTRIBUTOR DR RAVAL WILL JOIN
THE RANKS OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
VICE PRESIDENT HAVE ON HERE IS
THE FIRST WOMAN IN PERSON OF
COLOR TO HOLD AMERICA'S SECOND
HIGHEST OFFICE. BB HERE BUT
THERE ARE FIRST- LATINO AG ALEX
THE OTHER KIND OF IMMIGRANTS
NOW OUR FIRST BETWEEN OFFENDED
OR NOT TO MENTION AT OUR OTHER
WOMEN OF COLOR WHO HOLD
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES IN
CALIFORNIA TRACKER PANAMA
CONTROLLER BODY AND BOP MEMBER
EMILY ECHO AND DR WEBBER YOU
JOIN A DISTINGUISHED GROUP OF
PUBLIC SERVANTS. UPW MEMBERS
ARE CONFIDENT YOU WILL CONTINUE
TO FIGHT TO REDUCE OBSTACLES TO
VOTING FOR OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND CAN CREEP DEMOCRATIC
WHICH AT THE PATIENT FOR
TRADITIONALLY DISENFRANCHISED
AND EXCLUDED COMMUNITIES IN
FUTURE ELECTIONS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
DOCTOR WEBER IN YOUR NEW ROLE-
UPW STRONGLY SUPPORT YOUR
CONFIRMATION. ACT CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE. THANK YOU
VERY. MAR OR ANYONE ELSE IN
QUEUE TO SPEAK. WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND SEVENTEEN
YEAR ERA YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHICH COMMON.
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR COMMENT. YES MY
NAME IS JOHN WALDHOLTZ YEAH AND
I'VE BEEN A MODEL. WITH THAT.
ONE THIRTY FIVE YEAH- AND
REPRESENT OVER LOT- ALL OF THEM
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE FORM THAT
ARE ONE OF THEM THE- BATTERY IT
STEVEN SOCIETY. HONORS THE
OFFER THE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN MANAGE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL BUT SIMPLY THIS
IS THE VERY BEST A POINT THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IT MAY- DR-
WEBER AS A TEAM- AND THEY OF
THE SACREDNESS AND WE'RE
GEOLOGY ABOUT BIKES- WE
ANTICIPATE THAT SHE WILL BE A
FIERCE PROTECTOR. AND ADVANCE-
ALL THE RIGHTS AND WILL. A
BORDERS AS THERE ARE GREASING.
YES MA'AM FRANCHISE AN
IMPORTANT FOR ACTIONS ARE BONTA
ASSAULT ON. THIS IS THE USE OF
ONE YEAH AND I AM VERY THE
TESTIFIED IN DOCTOR LEVERAGES.
THE YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATORS
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE TO
SPEAK. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT UNTIL. THANK
YOU WITH THAT THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY PORTION OF THIS
HEARING IS NOW CLOSED. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO QUESTIONS IN THE
LIBERATION BY THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
DELIBERATIONS. BY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HELLO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR BERMAN I SIMONE
WOMAN AND WEBER ABOUT. WHEN I
WAS MADE AWARE OF THE
NOMINATION FOR SECRETARY STATE.
I SENT YOU A HAND WRITTEN NOTE
AND THAT NOTE I STATED THAT IT
YOUR SUCCESS IS OUR SUCCESS.
AND GENUINE IN THAT SAME
SENTIMENT AND IT'S VERY CLEAR
AND EVIDENT ESPECIALLY WITH
YOUR OPENING REMARKS THAT THIS
IS A GREAT NOMINATION- AND NOW
THAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES ABOUT THE QUALITY
OF THE CHARACTER AND WE GET
INTO THE- LESS. SEXY TOPICS
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
DAILY ACTIVITIES NOT JUST IN
TERMS OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE OUR
ELECTIONS. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO THAT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND SUPPORTING
BUSINESSES- WE HIGHLIGHTED TO
THIS COMMITTEE HIGHLIGHTED TO
EARLIER ABOUT SOME OF THE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES. WITH
RESPECT TO THE TECHNOLOGY AND
WE HAD MAY HAVE TO SPOKEN TO
ABOUT THIS EARLIER ABOUT THIS
IS IN REGARDS TO THAT OF REMOTE
ONLINE NOTARIZATION. AS YOU
KNOW AND THAT'S WHAT WE STATED
THAT TWENTY TWO STATES ALREADY
ALLOW ON EMERGENCY BASIS FOR
THE DURATION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES- THAT- FROM MODE
ONLINE ORDERS ATION. THE FACT
TWENTY SEVEN STATES HAVE
ALREADY PASSED LEGISLATION IN
THIS REGARD. UNFORTUNATELY TWO
STATES HAVE NOT ADOPTED ANY
LEGISLATION OR ALLOWED FOR THIS
REMOTE ONLINE NOTARIZATION
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTH CAROLINA.
A TO MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
THREE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS. PREVIOUSLY
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION MISTER
CALDERON MISS RUBIO AND OTHERS-
AND IT IS THE LEGISLATURE IS
UNDERSTANDING AND THE
COMMITTEES UNDERSTANDING THAT
SPECIFICALLY WAS THAT OF THE
TERMINATION OF THE SECRETARY
STATE TO HELP SUPPORT. AND
SHEPHERD THIS ISSUE MOVING
FORWARD SO THE FIRST QUESTION
IS WITH RESPECT TO AGAIN BECOME
A PANDEMIC SPECIFICALLY OF
COURSE THE UTILIZATION OF
REMOTE SIGNING AGREEMENTS
INCLUDING AGREEMENTS THAT
REQUIRED NOTARIZATION. WHETHER
NOT IT'S THAT AT THE LIFE AND
DEATH SITUATIONS OF WILLS AND
TRUSTS OR FINALIZING HOME SALES
OR COMPLETING OTHER FINANCIAL
DOCUMENTS THE EASE OF WAITING
DOING BUSINESS. DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT AS SECRETARY OF STATE THAT
YOU WOULD TAKE ON THIS ROLE
SERIOUSLY TO HELP PRIORITIZE
THAT OF MAKING SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA HELP SUPPORT HOME
GROWN. TECHNOLOGIES BUT ALSO
IMPLEMENTS WHAT WE KNOW IS
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE. I HAVE
ALREADY SPOKEN WITH THE STAFF
AT THAT UP IF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE I SPOKE WITH THEM IS TO
PUT. D. AS HE WAS OF- EXITING
IN THE BUSINESS AND- WE WAIT
FOR A NEW TO COME IN- SO THAT
WE CAN BEGIN TO WORK WITH THEM.
THE STAFF ON HAS BEEN INFORMED
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING I WANT TO
TAKE UP WITH THEM. IN TERMS OF
REMOTE VOTING I MEAN THE
NOTARIZATION THAT WE WANT TO
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO. AND THEY
ARGUE THAT THERE ARE SOME ALL
ISSUES OF SAFETY AND WHAT HAVE
YOU BUT I THINK THOSE THINGS
MADE COULD BE OVERCOME. SO
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT I'VE
GIVEN THEM THE- THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS SO WE WILL. DEFINITELY
BE LOOKING AT IT HOPEFULLY
GETTING SOME OF YOU INVOLVED IN
THE CONVERSATION- AND TO SEE
WHAT IS THE I DON'T HAVE AN
OPPOSITION TO IT IN OTHER WORDS
IT BUT I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT IT TO SAY YES LET'S DO
IT. BUT I'VE HEARD ABOUT IT AND
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO LOOK AT- WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT BLOCKCHAIN WITH REGARDS TO-
OF I ASKED THE STAFF ABOUT THAT
IN TERMS OF OUR PADS. IN SO
WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK AT THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S THERE WITH
THE NEW FRESH EYES AND
HOPEFULLY GETTING UP FOLKS
ENGAGED INVOLVED- JUST MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS THAT ARE THERE SO I
THINK- CALIFORNIA'S BOYS TO DO
IT. I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
OPPOSITION WAS BEFORE OTHER
THAN THAT. THEY THE CONCERN WAS
THERE IS A SECURITY CONCERN.
OKAY SO WE CAN LOOK AT THAT AND
BEGIN TO DEAL WITH IT SO I HAVE
TAKEN IT ON AS AN ITEM FOR THE
STAFF TO BEGIN TO. INVESTIGATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
CERTAINLY. DON'T EXPECT TO TAKE
A POSITION HERE SPECIFICALLY ON
THAT ISSUE BUT RATHER A BOTH A
MISTER BERMAN I HAIL FROM
SILICON VALLEY CAN HELP
DISCUSS. SOME OF THESE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES AGAIN IT'S I
THINK THE PRIORITY FOR THE
STATE TO LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
HOME GROWN TECHNOLOGIES AND
IMPLEMENT THEM ACCORDINGLY.
ESPECIALLY SEEING THAT FORMER
MAJORITY LEADER CALLED AROUND
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
FOLLOWED BY THEN SENATOR RUBIO
HAD. ATTEMPTED TO SHEPHERD THIS
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE BUT
AGAIN IT IS OUR COMMITTEES
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT WAS THAT
OF A HANG UP IN THE SECTOR
STATES OFFICE OF. VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION TO HELP WORK WITH
YOU IN PARTNER ON THAT TOO. AND
AS AS SIMILARLY IT IT WAS. ALSO
THE COMMITTEES- UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE HAS. RECENTLY ISSUED A
STATEMENT NOTING. THAT
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS WHO WISH.
D. TO HAVE THEIR- NOTARIZED
REMOTELY. CAN OBTAIN THE
SERVICES AND OTHERS. AND SO OF
COURSE ALONG THOSE LINES WE
LIKE TO HELP SUPPORT OUR OWN
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND
TECHNOLOGIES ASSUME THAT YOU'RE
SIMILARLY WOULD HELP SUPPORT
THE THAT AS WELL IF IT WILL WE
CAN WE CAN LOOK INTO THAT AS
WELL YES OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THEN MAYBE A TRANSITION
OUT OF THE IF YOU WILL BACK TO
ELECTIONS. SPECIFICALLY HAVE
YOU SUBMITTED BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE THAT OF YOUR SUPPORT
AND EXPANDING VOTER CONFIDENCE
AND PARTICIPATION. AS WELL AS
INSPIRING AND EXPANDING THE
RIGHTS TO ONCE ACCESS TO VOTE.
TO MAKE IT MORE CONVENIENT TO
REGISTER TO VOTE HE VINCE ITS
SUPPORT OF MAIL IN BALLOTS IN
PERSON VOTING EXPANDING VOTING
OPTIONS. SUPPORTING RESTORING
VOTING RIGHTS FOR EX FELONS. HE
ALSO STATED THAT. THE GOAL. IS
A 100% PARTICIPATION. OF VOTER
PARTICIPATION OF REGISTERED
VOTERS AND THE INCREASING VOTER
PARTICIPATION IS A CONSTANT
EFFORT- THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE LIKE TO LIKE TO SEE
ESPECIALLY KNOWING THAT WE
HAVE. AUTOMATED VOTER
REGISTRATION AT SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN. A MOVE ON PREPAID
POSTAGE OF ABSENTEE BALLOTS
PROPOSALS OF ELECTION DAY
HOLIDAY WHICH YOU'VE ALSO
SUPPORTED IN THE LEGISLATURE.
TO WHICH TWENTY TWO OTHER
STATES ALREADY HAS THIS IN LAW-
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD
HELP IN THIS CAPACITY IS A
STATEWIDE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS. ALSO SUPPORT- YES WE
HAVE TO DO ALL WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO VOTING AND I THINK
OUR OUR SYSTEM IN THE PAST HAS
BEEN VERY ARCHAIC IN VERY
ELITIST. THAT IT ONLY CAN
HAPPEN AT A CERTAIN PERIOD OF
TIME AND ON A CERTAIN DAY AND
ONE DAY A WEEK AND UP. I THINK
WE'VE SEEN AROUND THE WORLD
THAT- PEOPLE HAVE LONGER TIMES
TO VOTE YOU KNOW AND- AND
HAVING. A MORE ROBUST KIND OF
ENGAGEMENT IN VOTING AND THAT'S
OUR GOAL- AND I SAVE MY GO
2100% BECAUSE THAT MEANS WILL
COSTLY WORK ON IT IT'S YOU HAVE
YOU DON'T PUT YOUR AND YOU'LL
ALWAYS BE WORKING TO GET EVERY
PERSON THEY ARE. AND WE SHOULD
NEVER BE CONTENT 220% OF THE
PEOPLE DECIDED NOT TO SHOW UP
YOU KNOW ON SOMETHING AS
IMPORTANT AS VOTING. AND SO MY
GOAL IS ALWAYS TO BE WORKING TO
IT TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
FOLKS WHO CAN'T VOTE THAT
OPPORTUNITIES TO VOTE. AND I
JUST TO REGISTER THEM BUT TO
GET THEM TO THE POLLS. YOU KNOW
THAT THAT IS WHAT IS. IMPORTANT
THAT WOULD BE THERE YES.
CERTAINLY IN YOUR TALKED
EARLIER ABOUT THE IMPORTS OF
SIEVE. AND THAT. AND FRANCHISE
MEANT. AND HOW WE ARE ON OUR
COLLECTIVE JOURNEY AS A STATE.
TO HELP EXPAND VOTER ACCESS.
THERE THERE IS THIS NOTION THAT
I LEARNED ABOUT IN SCHOOL ABOUT
NO TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION. CURRENTLY THERE
ARE SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD WHO OF
COURSE AS YOU KNOW. I DO PAY
TAXES WHETHER BE MEDICARE
SOCIAL SECURITY FEDERAL INCOME
TAXES. DISABILITY INSURANCE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX AND OUR
SALES TAX. AS WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE TWENTY TWO STATES. IN
THE NATION THAT ALREADY ALLOW
FOR SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO VOTE
IN ELECTIONS. SHOULD THEY TURN
EIGHTEEN BY THE GENERAL
ELECTION. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN BERKELEY.
AND SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS
ANGELES AVE ALL EXPORT
PROPOSAL SIMILARLY TO L. HELP
EXPAND VOTING RIGHTS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE. ESPECIALLY WHEN WE WANT
TO FOCUS ON. ENSURINGTHAT
TRAJECTORY OF YOUNG PEOPLE- I
WONDERED IF THERE MIGHT BE AN
OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY NOW AS-
THAT OF THE CHIEF ELECTIONS
OFFICER FOR THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO. HAVE ANOTHER
LOOK AT THIS AS YOU KNOW. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
LEGISLATURE. WE PASSED A
MEASURE LIKE THIS WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH THAT
THE REPUBLICAN. MINORITY
LEADER. ALSO SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE I WONDER IF THE AS THE
CHIEF ELECTIONS OFFICER FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO HELP TAKE A SECOND
LOOK AT. HOW WE CAN HELP EXPAND
VOTER RIGHTS ESPECIALLY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE. I THINK WE ALWAYS
LOOK AT IT YOU KNOW I'M OPPOSED
TO IT. I HAVE VOTED AGAIN IT IN
THE PAST- AND OVERRIDE REASONS
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I'M NOT
I'M NOT THE RABBIT AGAINST IT
YOU KNOW AND- I HAVEN'T REALLY
SPOKEN ON THE FLOOR AGAINST IT-
BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE
VARIOUS POINTS OF VIEW AS TO
WHY PEOPLE THINK IT'S SEVENTEEN
VERSUS EIGHTEEN VERSUS SIXTEEN.
WE'VE HEARD EVEN TALK ABOUT IS
BEING SIXTEEN AND SO THERE'S
CERTAIN PARTICULAR PARTICULAR
REASONS WHY I THINK EIGHTEEN IS
A BETTER AGE AND UP. THEN SINCE
SEVENTEEN ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
HAVE CONFLICT BETWEEN WHAT WE
LAID OUT A LOT EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO DO AND WE HAVE RAISES.
THE UP THE AGE OF SMOKING I
THINK IT IS BECAUSE WE THINK
THEY'RE NOT MATURE ENOUGH TO
MAKE THAT DECISION YET THEY'RE
MATURE ENOUGH TO VOTE SO THAT
IT. SO THAT'S A CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAVE TO HALF. OFF AND I
WAS PLEASED THAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO GO TO THE POLLS.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S A
DECISION THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO MAKE AND- AND I DIDN'T LOBBY
AGAINST IT BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S ENOUGH THINGS THAT
CALIFORNIA THAT PEOPLE CAN TALK
ABOUT IT INTELLIGENTLY. AND
THEY VOTED AGAINST. US SO WE
CAN BEGIN THE CONVERSATION
AGAIN BUT UP BUT I THINK THAT
UP ONCE THEY VOTED AGAINST IT
IT'S LIKE WELL DO WE TAKE IT UP
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN IT'S
KIND OF LIKE. WHAT WE GONNA DO
ABOUT AFFIRMATIVE ACTION ARE WE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BEAT THAT
HORSE TO DO WE LOOK FOR
SOMETHING ELSE THAT MIGHT
EVENTUALLY. HELP PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND IT- BUT- BUT IT IS
IT IS SOMETHING TO CALIFORNIA
VOTED AGAINST IN THE LAST
ELECTION. A WITH A LOT OF
PROGRESSIVE THINGS ON THE
AGENDA THEY VOTED AGAINST IT
AND SO- WE CAN LOOK AT IT AGAIN
YOU'RE ONE OF THE THINGS I'VE
ALWAYS LEARNED IN MY LIFE IS
THAT IF THINGS HAVE CHANGED IS
THAT THERE'S ALWAYS CHANGE. IT
WAS ALWAYS CONVERSATION.
THERE'S ALWAYS AN OPPORTUNITY
AND- THAT'S PROBABLY MY
ACADEMIC BACKGROUND IT LOVES TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN- BUT I'M
ALWAYS OPEN TO THE CONVERSATION
IT'S THEIR- HAND UP AND WE CAN
SEE IF PEOPLE'S. MINDS HAVE
CHANGED IN TERMS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WITH VOTED
AGAINST. FORT IT DIDN'T MAKE
THE CHANGE. MAYBE IT'S TOO MANY
THINGS ON THE BALLOT I DON'T
KNOW. YOU KNOW. THAT ALWAYS
HAPPENS OF PEOPLE JUST GET
TIRED. AND DECIDED TO WANT EVEN
MORE CHANGE AND THAT'S IT. SO-
I THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
SO SEVENTEEN A THOSE WERE
ADVOCATES. WHICH FACE.
APPROACHABLE DIFFERENTLY. AND
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A PER.
WILLING TO LISTEN. AND A
CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
HAD SO THEY CAN UNDERSTAND IT
AND THAT MAY HAVE BEEN. IN THE
MIDST OF THE NOISE OF THE
ELECTION PEOPLE JUST DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT. SO WE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT YES
SHOULD WE LEAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS PROBABLY SO TO
SEE PEOPLE INTERESTED. AND I'D
BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THOSE WHO HAVE IT AS A- AS A
MAJOR AGENDA. ITEM TO BEGIN TO
TALK ABOUT IT. YOU KNOW. AND I
THINK COMMUNITIES A VERY
DIFFERENT ONE OF THE THINGS I
DISCOVERED WITH MY COLLEAGUES
IN SAN DIEGO'S DEPENDING ON
WHAT NEIGHBORHOOD YOU LIVE IN.
DEPENDS ON WHAT YOUNG PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT VOTING. YOU KNOW IN
THE SAME IN THE SAME AREA WHERE
I HAVE TWO YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
WERE MORE. EMANCIPATED BECAUSE
OF ITS LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES MAYBE
THEIR PARENTS DIDN'T SPEAK
ENGLISH OR WHATEVER MAY BE- TWO
ACTIVE THEY WERE VERY IN FAVOR
OF SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS
VOTING. IN OTHER COMMUNITIES
WHERE THERE WAS AND- THERE WERE
TWO PARENTS IN THE HOUSEHOLD
AND ALL THESE. THINGS THEY WERE
VERY OPPOSED TO IT. SO WE HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT WE HAD
BOTH OF THEM. BASICALLY OPPOSED
TO ON DIFFERENT SIDES OF THE
CONVERSATION SO I THINK THERE'S
A CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
HAD. BUT IT'S NOT ALL ONE ONE
DIRECTION AS WE SOMETIMES THINK
IN THE LEGISLATURE. YOU KNOW.
WHAT THAT THE I THINK THAT'S
AGAIN AND CORN AND SPINACH
ESPECIALLY. A SPIRIT OF
FRANCHISING IT. THESE IN. ARE
EIGHTEEN. BY THE- ELECTION BUT
BECAUSE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUALLY MOVES. ARE
PRIMARIES FROM JUNE TO MARCH.
YOU HAVE A SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION. ESPECIALLY YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND WHAT HOW WHAT A
BETTER WAY TO HELP INSPIRE AND
SEEING ELECTED OFFICIALS. TO
INSPIRE THEM TO BE THE NEXT
FREELY WEAPONS OF THE WORLD IN
WHICH WE GO ON HIGH SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. AND WE HAVE BEEN
TRULY. HAVE A SENSE OF VOTING.
INSPIRED THAT SENSE AND SO AT
LEAST THE OPEN CONVERSATION. AS
WE EVOLVE AND THINK ABOUT THEN
THE ROLE. AS THE CHIEF
ELECTIONS OFFICER FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE. NOT JUST ONE
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATRE. OF
COURSE KEEPING OPEN MINDED
THAT. AND IT WAS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. AND IT'S AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE
ALLEGE THE SECTOR STATE DOES
GOING TO BEGIN THE IRVINE. AND
BRIDGES TO YOUNG PEOPLE EARLY-
AND WE DID A LOT OF THOSE THAT
THEY DID A LOT THIS PAST YEAR
TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE READY
FOR. WHEN THAT WHENEVER THE
TIME WAS TO COME TO VOTE- AND
SO- WE- THERE'S A ROBUST HIGH
SCHOOL PROGRAM. THAT GOES INTO
REGISTERED YOUNG PEOPLE TO
VOTE. AND I KNOW THERE'S ALSO A
PROGRAM THAT HELPS YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO WORK AT THE POLLS. SHOULD
BASICALLY BEGIN TO WORK THE
POST TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT. AT
THE CIVIC RESPONSIBILITY IS SO-
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
YES. HI THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHAIR LOW. ANY OTHER.
OR COMMENTS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I HAVE A QUICK QUESTION DR
WEBER. THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS
CHOICE ACT WAS ENACTED DURING
YOUR TIME AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE FIFTEEN
COUNTIES MAKING UP MORE THAN
HALF OF THE STATE'S VOTERS USED
THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT TO
CONDUCT ELECTIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY. DO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
EXPANDTHE USE OF THE VOTERS
FOR A SECOND CALIFORNIA- IF SO
SHOULD THE STATE MANDATE THAT
ALL COUNTIES CONDUCT ELECTIONS
USING THEM ALL- AND IF YOU DO
NOT SUPPORT MANDATING COUNTIES
USE THAT MODEL HOW MIGHT WE
ENCOURAGE MORE COUNTIES. TO DO
SO VOLUNTARILY WELL I THINK YOU
KNOW THAT TOO ISN'T AN ISSUE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE IF THEY
WANT TO ACTUALLY MANDATE THOUGH
THEM TO USE IT WE PASSED IT- WE
PASS IT WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT PEOPLE COULD OPT IN AND
OPT OUT OKAY- I THINK WE
DEMONSTRATED IN THIS LAST
ELECTION THAT IT IS A GOOD
CHOICE. AND IT'S AND PROVIDING
MULTIPLE CHOICES FOR VOTING IT
IS GREAT- THE LEGISLATURE COULD
MANDATE IT AND I WOULD I WOULD
PROBABLY BE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THEM DOING THAT- AND BECAUSE I
THINK IT DOES BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF ACCESSIBILITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS A
CHANCE TO VOTE IN THOSE KIND OF
THINGS I'M NOT SURE IF THERE'S
ANY OPPOSITION TO IT AT THIS
POINT. THE ONLY OPPOSITION
HERBAL SOMEWHAT FOLKS WANTED A
FIVE SHORTER TIME FRAME THREE
DAYS VERSUS TWO WEEKS IN TERMS
OF PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO GO TO
THE POLLS AT NIGHT AND I MIGHT
MY RECOMMENDATION WAS LET'S
LET'S BASICALLY MAKE IT SO THAT
THERE'S A MINIMUM OF THREE DAYS
WHICH MEANS THE LOSS AND IT'S
COULD HAVE A WEEK AND A HALF.
YOU KNOW SMALLER COUNTIES CAN
HAVE THREE FOUR DAYS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT SHOWS UP TO GIVE
THEM THE FLEXIBILITY BUT I
THINK WE LEARNED A LOT IN THIS
LAST ELECTION THAT IT THAT IT
IS NOT THAT IT IS REALLY OF THE
THINGS WE PUT IN PLACE OF
REALLY GOOD THINGS. THAT IT
REALLY OPENS UP PEOPLE'S
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE AND THEN WE
HAVE SOMETIMES GOTTEN PAST THE
FEAR OF- VOTING BY MAIL.
BECAUSE I CAN REMEMBER- WORKING
A CAMPAIGN BACK IN THE EIGHTIES
I THINK IT WAS AND IT WAS LIKE
HILL GETTING PEOPLE IN AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO VOTE BY
MAIL. AND I UNDERSTOOD THEIR
FEARS THEIR FEARS WHERE THEY
HAD. BEEN FOR THE SOUTH THE NEW
PEOPLE WOULDN'T TAKE THEY'RE
BACK. YEARS WOULD BE MY THOUGHT
AWAY. THEY WANT TO PERSONALLY
PUT IT IN THE- BOX. THIS TIME I
THINK PEOPLE LAW. AND BECAUSE
OF THE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WERE DONE IN THE VOTING CENTERS
AND OTHER KINDS OF THINGS IN
THE OPPORTUNITIES OVER THERE
AND- ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
PEOPLE BECAME MUCH MORE
AGREEABLE TO IT WILL
COMFORTABLE AND PLUS BEING IN A
PANDEMIC IT FELT IT WAS SAFER.
AND THEN THE RESULTS THAT CAME
OUT THAT SHOWED THE LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO VOTED THAT
THEY'VE THEIR BALLOTS WERE
TOSSED OUT WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
KIND OF. THINGS THAT THE PEOPLE
ARGUED ABOUT ACROSS THE NATION.
AND SO I THINK AT THIS POINT
PEOPLE OF A MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE. YOU KNOW IT TOOK A
WHILE. BUT I THINK WE'RE READY
FOR IT AT THIS POINT. I AM
BIASED BUT I AGREE- THE COUNTRY
SAW. PRESIDENT LEVELS IN IN
THIS IS A BIG CONCERN FOR ME OF
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION IN CONNECTION.
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL
ELECTION- INCLUDING
UNFORTUNATELY FROM ELECTED
OFFICIALS. WHO SHOULD REALLY
KNOW BETTER. WHAT ROLE DOES THE
SECRETARY OF STATE HAVE IN
HELPING TO COMBAT- YOU KNOW
THESE MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION WARS THAT ARE
BEING WAGED. WELL ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED THIS LAST
YEAR THEY HAD- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
THAT DOES OUTREACH. AND IN MY
CONVERSATION WAS WITH WITH MANY
OF THEM TO SAID WE NEED TO.
EXPAND THOSE NUMBERS TO DO
OUTREACH. ARE NOT JUST IN TERMS
OF REGISTERED PEOPLE TO VOTE.
BUT WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT INFORMATION THAT COMES
OUT. IS COUNTERED. COUNTED BY
WILL BE CALLED TRUSTED
MESSENGERS. SO THAT PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITY SAID THAT YOU CAN
REACH OUT TO NON BUSINESSES AND
BARBER SHOPS AND PLACES WOULD
YOU CAN PUT INFORMATION. SO
THAT PEOPLE KNOW. THAT WHAT THE
CORRECT INFORMATION IS ABOUT
AND SO WE HAVE TO REALLY BE
VERY ENGAGING VERY INVOLVED. IN
MAKING SURE THAT THE
INFORMATION IS CLEAR THAT THAT.
IF THERE IS MISINFORMATION AND
WE ARE RESPONDING TO IT. THAT
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PERSONS AND
COMMUNITIES WHETHER THE LECTIN
OFFICIALS OR SECRETARY OF STATE
OR WHOEVER IT IS. THAT IS A
TRUSTED MESSENGER THAT CAN
ACTUALLY TELL PEOPLE THIS IS
WHAT IT'S REALLY BOUT. AND
HAVE THOSE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM ABOUT.
THE MISINFORMATION IS THERE. SO
THAT WILL ALWAYS BE AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE. BECAUSE AS WE MADE-
THE ABILITY TO SPREAD MESSAGES
EASIER. FROM THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. NOW WE HAVE TO ALSO
KIND OF THOSE MESSAGES WHEN
THEY COME UP AND THAT AND SO
THERE IS A SECTION. IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
THAT HAS TO BE INCREASED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ALWAYS ON
TOP OF. RESPONDING TO THE
MISINFORMATION THAT'S THE IT.
AND USING OUR OUR OUR LIKE TO
OFFICIALS TO HELP US DO THAT.
CREATING THINGS FOR YOU TO PUT
ON YOUR WEBSITE TO. UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE INFORMATION IS ABOUT.
AND BEING ON TOP OF IT SO THAT
WE CAN- FIRST HOPEFULLY SQUASH
THE INFORMATION AS IT COMES OUT
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF.
MISINFORMATION IT IS FOR IT.
AND IT SPREADS RATHER QUICKLY.
WITHOUT. IF YOU DON'T RESPOND
TO IT. SO MY GO IS TO TRY TO.
THOSE FOR WHO IS THE ALBUM BUT
TOOK. IN THE OF MR. AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE GOOD. OUT FOR THE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NEW
VOTING RULES ARE. WHERE THEY
WHERE THEY CAN GO VOTE YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE BALLOT
YOU KNOW THE SPECIFIC MASON
WILL THEY WON'T COUNT OF THE
TWO WEEKS IT WILL YOU KNOW.
KIND OF STUFF. WE CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT QUICKLY TO
PEOPLE SO THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR FOCUS AND PASSION FOR
THAT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS PLEASE MR OLDHAM. THE
DOCTOR WEBER I THINK- YOU'VE
DEMONSTRATED YOURSELF OVER
THESE LAST TWO YEARS TO BE A
PROLIFIC. LEGISLATOR AND FROM
TIME TO TIME THE LEGISLATURE
HAS HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECEIVE SPONSORED LEGISLATION
FROM OUR STATEWIDE. ELECTED
OFFICIALS DO YOU SEE- FORESEE
AN OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU WOULD.
LOOK TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE NUMBER THERE A LOT
OF IDEAS THAT HAVE BEEN TALKED
ABOUT TODAY BUT EVEN GOING
FORWARD I KNOW THAT LAST YEAR
WE SAW A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
ARE REALLY ENGAGED AROUND
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND MAKING SURE
THEIR VOICES WERE HEARD IT WAS
REALLY RATHER INSPIRING TO SEE
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROCESS. AND SO I GUESS I'M
JUST WITHIN THAT THAT AREA ARE
YOU- THINKING THAT THAT MIGHT
BE A WAY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON IDEAS
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE WANTED TO
PURSUE HAD YOU- CONTINUE TO BE
IN THE LEGISLATURE. YOU KNOW-
AS I TELL FOLKS I'M ONLY GOING
ACROSS THE STREET SO. I WOULD
DEFINITELY BE ENGAGED IN
INVOLVED IN IN LEGISLATION THAT
DEALS WITH ISSUES OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THE WHOLE PROCESS
OF. THE VOTING IS ABOUT
EMPOWERING PEOPLE TO FIGHT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S SOME
JUSTICE FOR EVERYBODY IN THIS
COUNTRY- IN ADDITION TO THAT I
HAVE A PACKET OF LEGISLATION
THAT I'M LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW
THAT THAT THAT THAT. THAT MANY
OF YOU HAVE AUTHORED AS WELL AS
A SECOND HERE STATE'S
RECOMMENDATION OF THINGS THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN- SO AND SO WE'VE
THERE WILL BE A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN. THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE AND ELECTIONS AS
WE ALWAYS HAVE HAD- IN TERMS OF
THIS PARTICULAR IDEAS AND
ISSUES THAT COME FORWARD- THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT BECAUSE EVERY
ELECTION BRINGS IN CHALLENGES
AND OBVIOUSLY BUT MAKES US LOOK
AT THINGS DIFFERENTLY THE
VOTING BOX THING IS. YOU KNOW
IT IS BIG AND IT'S OUT THERE
AND EVEN THOUGH DIDN'T CAUSE
MUCH DOES DO ITS DAMAGE IS THE
MEDIA HAD THOUGHT IT WOULD BUT
IT IT REMINDED US THAT THERE
ARE SOME THINGS WE HAVE TO
TIGHTEN UP. AND I THINK WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT- THAT ALREADY A
LITTLE BIT SO WE WILL BE I WILL
BE ENGAGE WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON THOSE ISSUES AS WELL AS
ISSUES OF SOCIAL JUSTICE. YES
LET ME JUST SAY THAT- MORE
PROBABLY ONE OF. A REGRET THAT
I HAVE- WHEN I WAS AT SAN DIEGO
STATE AND I DID NOT TAE YOUR
COURSE- BUT THEN AS I. YOU KNOW
I WAS THERE AT THE SAME TIME AS
SENATOR BRADFORD- AND THE LOOK
ON HIS FACE WHEN HE WALKED OUT
OF YOUR- CLASSROOM SUGGESTED
THAT. YOUR COURSES WERE RATHER
DIFFICULT IT PROBABLY WAS A
GOOD THING THAT I DID NOT. TAKE
THEIR COURSES BUT I DO REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR FRIENDSHIP
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORKING WITH YOU. YOU'LL
START. I FIRMLY. THAT MY- WOULD
RIP. ME AT SOME POINT AND I HAD
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN DO
IT WELL. MR FOR. ERIC MISERABLE
TIMES YOUR ULTIMATE GOAL AND
THAT I AGREE WITH THAT THE
OUTER MY CONTACT JUST BECAUSE-
WAS TO GET HOW TO PRECIPITOUS
THE PATIENT- IN AND I THINK
THAT'S AN AWESOME GOAL THAT WE
AS AMERICANS SHOULD STRIVE FOR
AND IT'S A VERY NOBLE GOAL WITH
THAT ALSO COMES ACCURACY I DO
WE TRUST OUR VOTING SYSTEM. AND
GIVEN THE PRESSURES YOUR
PREDECESSOR ALLOW THE
CALIFORNIA VOTER ROLLS TO
BECOME IN THE WORDS OF THE
CARTER BAKER COMMISSION
INVITATION TO FRAUD HOW WOULD
YOU A SECRETARY STATE INSURE.
THE ONLY ELIGIBLE CITIZENS. CAN
BE CAN. AND CAN VOTE ONLY ONCE
IN AN ELECTION AND IN THAT.
LIKE WHAT CAN WE DO. AND THE
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL LAW I
THINK THESE THINGS ARE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT- FOR THE
CONTINUITY OF OUR OUR VOTE. NO
QUESTION THAT- THAT WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
VOTING ARE ELIGIBLE AND THAT WE
ARE CONSTANTLY WORKING TO MAKE
SURE WE SCREW UP OUR LIST TO
MAKE SURE THOSE WHO ARE
DECEASED TENTACLES OF LEFT THE
STATE. AND NO LONGER ON OUR
ROLES IN MY CONVERSATION WITH
THE STAFF- THEY'VE- IT IN AND
TALKING WITH THEM YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO WORK HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE- THAT WE ARE
IN LINE WITH THE VARIOUS
COUNTIES THAT ARE GIVING US
REPORT TO COME IN THAT THEY ARE
IN LINE WITH THAT. THE FOLKS
WHO PROVIDE DATA SAID
STATISTICS WITH REGARDS TO
DEATHS AND MOVEMENTS AND ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE
THERE A SYSTEM AS LARGE MAY
HAVE A FEW BUT HOPEFULLY NOT
VERY MANY IN TERMS OF. WELL
REPORTING AND SO BUT I'VE I'VE
ASKED HIM TO GIVE ME A COPY OF
THE REPORT TO SEE EXACTLY WHO
IS HOW HOW MANY INCIDENTS THAT
THAT WAS WHERE THEY ARE IN IN
TERMS OF THAT. WELL WE'VE SEEN.
A LOT OF- I. IT WAS A LOT OF
THINGS IN A BETTER ARE PEOPLE
OR IT'S IN TERMS OF BATTLES
FOUR OF SUPERVISORS REGISTER
VOTER THAT IT THAT IT THAT IT
KINDS OF I WANT MY BEST TRY TO
WORK WITH EACH OF THOSE THE
RICH VOTER TO GET THEM BOARD TO
HELP THEM JUST HOW IMPORTANT
THE WORK IS THAT THEY DO THAT
IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE I DON'T
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
PARTISAN EVEN I'M A DEMOCRAT I
DON'T TAKE THIS AS A PARTISAN
JOB BECAUSE I WANT EVERY
REPUBLICAN TO VOTE. AND I WANT
TO FRANCHISE ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE ANY TIME
ANY GROUP IS THIS WHAT IS IT
FEELS A BIT NOT IN FRANCHISE
YOU HAVE THE OUTBREAKS IN THE
THINGS THAT OCCUR THAT WE SEEM
BECAUSE PEOPLE FEEL THAT
THEY'RE NOT BEING HEARD IN SO
LONG MAKES EVERYONE HEARD OF
BUT WE WILL BE WORKING TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE DATA
THAT COMES IN IT IS ACTUALLY
SCRUB THAT THERE THAT WOULD ARE
PULLED OUT ROLES ARE. AS MY AS
ONE CLASS CAN BE ACCURATE AND
WITH THE STATE THE SIZE WITH WE
HAVE SEVENTEEN ALMOSTEIGHTEEN
MILLION VOTE THIS PASS TIME-
CAN I TELL YOU ALL EIGHT OF
WERE- WERE FOLKS WHO VOTE HOPE
SO- DID I CAN I YOU THE ONE OF
TWO PEOPLE D. GET THE RIGHT
BACK I WISH I COULD SAY THEY
DIDN'T YOU KNOW BUT WHAT
EIGHTEEN THAT WE CAN WOULD
WE'RE BACK FOR HER. TO ACTORS
YEAH NO APPRECIATE THAT AND I'M
WE COME BACK A THE VERY
INTEREST ELECTION CYCLE YOU
KNOW WE HAD MASSIVE OUT YOU
KNOW EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW FOR
PRESIDENT SEVENTY VOTE FOR
FORMER AND WHICH IS EXCITING
AND A LOT WAYS BUT WHAT THAT
SHOW US IS WE HAVE A COUNTRY
AND I THINK FOR AS CALIFORNIA
THE LARGEST IN THE WORLD.
ELECTED TO. OURSELVES IN
LEADING THE WAY AS IT IS TO. ON
BEING. ABOVE AND BE. LEAVE THE
COUNTRY IN A LOT OF. FRONTS YOU
ARE THERE ARE. PERSON THAT THE
RIGHT TIME. TO BRING. A OF KERR.
WE THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS. THAT
OUR RULES. ARE ACCURATE. AND I
LOVE THE FACT. YOU MAKE A I DID
I HEAR CA. FROM THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO LOOK INTO THIS BECAUSE
THERE IS A LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE
THAT THE- OF TRUST THAT'S
MISSING RIGHT NOW. THANK HAVE
TO BRING THAT BACK. BECAUSE
YOUR ABILITY TO VOTE IS ONE A
BETTER OX. OF OUR ACCOUNT OF
OUR COUNTRY. OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
IT'S INCREDIBLY ENCOURAGING
THAT YOUR HERE AT THIS TIME AND
SO I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU
LIKE TO DO I AND I AND I KNOW
THIS BUT- PLEASE TAKE THE
SERIOUS BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY OF US THAT ARE ROOTING FOR
YOU. THAT WANT OUR STATE TO BE
ON THE- THE PRECIPICE TO BE
WHAT EVERYBODY STRIVES WHEN IT
COMES TO VOTER ROLLS SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND THEN ON
THE TOP OF THE OF. MAIL IN
BALLOTS- ROQUE WOULD YOU
SUPPORT. I MEAN GIVING SOME OF
THOSE. DANGERS YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD A COME. ACTUALLY
INTERESTING- YOU KNOW THE AFTER
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO DIDN'T
LIKE MAIL IN BALLOTS AND IT
ALMOST IS LIKE FLIPPED YOU KNOW.
SUDDENLY THERE WAS A BACK- ID
ON THIS. WHAT CAN WE- TO MAKE
SURE THAT LIKE THE COUNTIES.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
DECISIONS AND WOULD YOU SUPPORT
THE STATE COMING AND BASICALLY
TAKING AWAY THAT COUNTY ABILITY
FOR MAIL IN BALLOTS. AND YOU
KIND OF TOUCHED ON JUST EVER SO
BRIEFLY ON WORKING WITH YOU
KNOW THE OFFICE OF. VOTE BUT-
IT WOULD YOU SUPPORT TAKING
THAT DECISION AWAY FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON THE MAINLAND
OUTSIDE. I WILL HOPE THAT- YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT YOU FOLKS
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO BASICALLY
DECIDE OF BECAUSE YOU WRITE THE
LEGISLATION AS TO WHETHER THAT
IT'S A MANDTE VERSUS EIGHTY- A
SUGGESTION. THAT THERE- I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT SO ATTRACTIVE ENOUGH
THAT PEOPLE WOULD WANT TO DO
IT. NO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
HEARD FROM- ONE OF THE NEWS.
PER PERSON WAS INTERVIEWING ME
BASICALLY SAY THAT. MANY OF THE
REGISTRARS OF VOTERS THIS TIME
REALLY LIKE WHAT TOOK PLACE
BECAUSE WE GAVE THE MONEY TO
GET IT DONE. YOU KNOW WE
PROVIDED THEM WITH THE STAFF
THAT WAS ESSENTIAL TO DEAL WITH
THE ABSENTEE BALLOTS AND MAIL
IN BALLOTS AND ALL THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS. WHAT WE DIDN'T
BEFORE. I THINK IT'S AS MUCH AS
WE CAN GET OUR PUBLIC OR
COUNTIES AND OTHERS TO BE
COOPERATIVE AND TO BE
SUPPORTIVE. YOU KNOW IT'S
ALWAYS BETTER IT'S ALWAYS
BETTER THAN A MANDATE IT REALLY
IS IF YOU CAN GET PEOPLE TO
WORK WITH YOU. CAN THEY I'M NOT
SURE BECAUSE I'VE SEEN SOME
THINGS THIS IS SOME WILL AND
SOME WON'T- BUT THE MAIN THING
IS THAT WE MUST MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIA HAS ACCESS TO
A BALLOT. AND ACCESS TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE AND THAT'S
THEN THAT'S WHAT'S THE MOST
CRITICAL THING WHETHER IT'S
MILLION OR NOT- MILLION MAKES
IT CONVENIENT FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO GET A MAIL IN BALLOT
BUT THEN THEY SHOULD. IF THEY
GET A MAIL BALLOT THEY SHE'LL
SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TURN IT IN. AND THAT'S WHY I
FIRMLY BELIEVE BECAUSE THERE
ARE SOME FOLKS WHO DO NOT WANT
TO PUT THE STUFF IN THE MAIL.
AND WHO FEEL THE MAIL SLOW. I
MEAN I GOT SOME STUFF THE OTHER
DAY THAT WAS MAILED ME IN
NOVEMBER I'M GONNA BE VERY
HONEST WITH YOU AGAIN LEBANESE.
EDUCATION AND I'M A LITTLE
UPSET THE I GOT TWO DAY AGO
BUT- BUT THEY A WHOLE LOT FOLKS
WHO DON'T MAN. YOU MAY IT TO
THE- BUT THEY WANT TO BE ABLE
TO WALK TO PLAY AND PUT IT IN
AND- WHAT. WITH THE ALL THE
BUILDINGS. THE MAIL THE- I DID.
BY THAT PEOPLE CAN A MAN I MINE
IN THE- INTO THE- OF THE
LIBRARY OF MY- LIBRARY. I MEAN.
HAVING THAT OF. TO PAY IS IN
OUR AND SHE ALWAYS BE AN OPTION.
PEOPLE SUB EVERY JUST AT. JUST
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PUT. IN BOX.
YOU KNOW. AND TO DO THE- AND
THEN. I THINK THAT. EXTREME
IMPORTANT. AND WHICH ALWAYS
THAT IS AND I. THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO. IF YOU DON'T WANT TO MAIL
IT. YOU DON'T HAVE TO. EVEN IF
WE MAY IF WE SAY. EVERY ABOUT.
THE HAVE THE AFTER TO BE- IT
INTO. YEAH WHAT I. DID EXACTLY
AS- THING. BY MAIL ABOUT AND
WHY. IN THE- YEAH AND I. DON'T
THAT IF WE- IF WE LOOK AT OUR
VOTE. ROLLS A LOT THIS THIS-
MAIL IN BALLOTS THAT. KIND OF
GOES A- IF. TRUST THE RULES
ACCURATE YEAH IF I. IT'S ALL.
ACTION THAT THAT BE. EXTRA POOR.
FOR AND KEEP IN MIND YOU KNOW
NOT AND I. FROM THE- POINT OF
VIEW. I GUESS. WHERE I. THAT
WOULD. THE BEST CAN. BUT I WAS
FROM A- WHERE PEOPLE. DO THE-
THEY COULD. AND- AND SOME. KIND
OF THE VOTER ROLL. AND- AND-
AND WE'RE- NOT IT'S FEAR WITHIN
THAT. TAKEN OFF SHOULDN'T BE.
OFF KNOWN PULLED. EEN TAKE OFF
THE- TO- EARLY. AND THEY DIDN'T.
IN A LETTER AND DIDN'T. DID NOT.
THEM WHATEVER IT MAY BE AND
THEY- GO. TO GET READY TO VOTE
IN. NOT ON THE- SO THE- FOLKS
ARE EQUALLY IF. THEN HAVING YOU
KNOW THE DEATH. BIT PERSON.
COME TO YOUR HOUSE. WE THEY'VE
BEEN A DISTANT. BECAUSE OF. US
NOT HAVING A- PROCESS. AND WHEN
WE IT HAPPEN. IT IS. PEOPLE
KIND. IN VOTING- A- IF THEY-
AND WHEN. BEEN CUT A LOT. OUT
OF THIS. IN FRANCHISE IN
CALIFORNIA. I COMPLETELY AGREE
AND TO. ENSURE I APPRECIATE YOU
CORRECTING THE RECORD- PRESENT
BY GOT EIGHTY ONE MILLION VOTED
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT SEVENTY
FOUR MILLION SO I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER HALL. WILLIAM IS DURING
THIS WORLD I AT. IT WOULD TAKE
A MILLION YEAH. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS LEADER IS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I TO- OUT.
FILLING OUT FELLOW IT TOOK AND
DROVE IT TO THE RED AND IT
THERE- AND REGARDING THE ROLES
I MY UNCLE DIED AFTER THE
PRIMARY AS A RESULT OF KOPET
BEFORE THAT THE GENERAL
ELECTION AND THE NOTICE WAS
RECEIVED THAT HIS NAME HAD BEEN
TAKEN OFF. SO I APPRECIATE AT
LEAST SAMBAR TO DINO COUNTY WAS
DOING IT RIGHT. MY QUESTION IS
CLEARLY WE HAD AN AMAZING
TURNOUT THIS LAST ELECTION I
WITH A RECORD HIGH OF 80% JUST
AS YOU'VE DISCUSSED EARLIER AND
MY QUESTION IS WHAT ARE YOUR
PLANS TO CONTINUE THE SUCCESS.
WELL I THINK PART OF IT AS A
STATE IS THAT IT ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU LEARN IS THAT THERE
ARE THINGS THAT PEOPLE VOTE. OF
FOUR AND THAT'S IMPORTANT- BUT
HAPPENS WHEN WE DON'T VOTE AT
ALL. AND UNFORTUNATELY OUR
COMMUNITIES DON'T SEE THE FLIP
SIDE. THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
LACK OF RESOURCES THAT COME
INTO A COMMUNITY WHEN YOU DON'T
BOOK. OF THE LACK OF
REPRESENTATION THAT HAPPENS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T VOTE.
AND SO WE HAVE TO BEGIN TO
EDUCATE THEM ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE COIN IS NOT ONLY WHY YOU
VOCAL WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DON'T. AND THAT BECOMES
IMPORTANT WE DO THAT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ISSUES
LIKE CIVIC EDUCATION OUTREACH
EFFORTS THAT ARE GOING OUT TO
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES. MAKING
SURE THAT WE THAT WE HAVE MORE
THAN JUST A SUGGESTION FOR
YOUNG FIRMANDO COMING UP ROLE
BUT TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING AT NOT
GIVING A LITTLE. AND A HOST OF
THINGS WE COULD REGISTER AT THE
SAME TIME TO VOTE. I'M MAKING
SURE THEY GET THE CORRECT
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT. THAT
WILL INCREASE HOPEFULLY THE
NUMBER PERSON TO ON THE PHONE
THE FOOTBALL OF ROLES TO VOTE.
BUT ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE DO
THE KIND OF- OUTREACH AND
PUBLICITY THAT'S ALWAYS CENTRAL
AS WE GET IT. AS WE GET TOWARD
THE VOTING- TIME FRAME THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT
IT'S TIME TO VOTE THEN AND IF
IT AND EMPHASIZING A VERY
POSITIVE WAY TO THINGS THAT ARE
GOING ON. LOADING IT. THE ABOUT
IT- IT WAS A MAY IN THE
ELECTION IN GEORGIA. ARE HOW
YOU KNOW JAZZ WORK BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT THAT THAT THIS VOTE
MEANT SOMETHING. AND WE NEED TO
HELP HELP HELP PEOPLE CONTINUE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THESE VOTES
COUNT. AND AND NOW THAT WE'VE
GOT THE MOMENTUM IT'S A
QUESTION OF DO WE KEEP THE
MOMENTUM AND WE KEEP IT BACK
POSSIBLY PUTTING UP THE
PUBLICITY THE RELATIONSHIP.
MAKE USING OUR TRUSTED
MESSENGERS USING OUR OUTREACH
EFFORTS TO CONSTANTLY TALK
ABOUT WHY PEOPLE NEED TO GO TO
THE POLLS AND WHY THEY. NEED TO
VOTE. THANK YOU AND- CHAIR.
BERMAN CHAIR LOW- WOULD YOU
ENTERTAIN. YES PLEASE. I MOVE
THAT THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE
RECKON THAT THE IS ADVICE AND
TO THE APPOINT BY THE GOVERNOR
OF SURELY AND WE'RE AS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE FOR CAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE A
AND A- DOCTOR WEBER YOU LIKE AN
ADVERT FOR ANY CLOSING. I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS FOR
BEING- FOR THE YEARS THAT I'VE
WORKED WITH A OF YOU- I THINK
ONE OF YOU CAME WITH ME. AT THE
TIME- BUT I WILL VALUE YOUR
FRIENDSHIP YOUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH BILLS THAT WE WORKED ON
TOGETHER BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I
VALUE THE FACT THAT I WORK WITH
SEVENTY NINE PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND REALLY
DESPITE WHATEVER DIFFERENCES WE
MIGHT HAVE BELIEVE IN THE STATE
BELIEVE IN THIS NATION AND
REALLY WANT TO MAKE IT WORK AND
EVEN THOSE WHO FEEL SOMETIMES
DISENFRANCHISED- WHAT THIS
COUNTRY TO WORK I AM TOTALLY
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT.
MY ANCESTORS MY MOTHER AND
FATHER WOULD ALWAYS BE PROUD OF
THE FACT THAT I'VE FOUGHT FOR
IT THE PERSON WHO HELPED ME TO
BECOME WHO I AM. I STAND ON THE
SHOULDERS OF SOME AMAZING
PEOPLE WHO WERE STRONG AND
DETERMINED BUT THEY WEREN'T
FAMOUS THEY WON'T EVEN WELL
KNOWN IN IN IN SOMETIMES DON'T
COMMUNITIES BUT WHAT THEY GAVE
ME WAS A SENSE OF PURPOSE AND
PROSPECTIVE. AND A DEBT THAT I
OWE TO THEM FOR ALL THE THINGS
THEY GIVE TO ME I AM INDEBTED
TO CALIFORNIA I HAVE THREE
DEGREES AND- TWELVE HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS FROM UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. THERE'S NO GREATER
GIFT IF YOU CAN GIVE A CHILD
THAT IN EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
GAVE ME THAT AND AN OPPORTUNITY
SO I HOPE IN SOME WAY THAT I
WILL BE ABLE TO REFLECT THAT
GIFT. TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND
TO ALL THE NATION BECAUSE THESE
ARE CRITICAL TIMES IN WHICH WE
MUST FIGHT TO MAINTAIN A VERY
FRAGILE DEMOCRACY BUT A VERY
PRECIOUS. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU WEBER AND IT
WOULDN'T NOTICE TO THE OTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS AYE I
THINK SECRETARY OF STATE IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT STATEWIDE
POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE- IN
CALIFORNIA. HI IN THIS. WHEN I
WASN'T WORKING IN THE VOTING SO.
OF THE STORE DIVISION THE
JUSTICE. IN WASHINGTON. I HAVE
WORKED ON CAN'T. AND DAKOTA CAN.
AND THE VOTER PROTECTION ON
NATIVE- A MONTH- I'M ALSO THE
GRANTS. AND SON AND HUSBAND. OF
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS- AND I
PRACTICED CORPORATE LAW BEFORE
I WAS ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY
IN. THE THOSE ROLES THAT YOU
WILL OVERSEE. AS SECRETARY OF
STATE ARE SO IMPORTANT TO ALL
FORTY MILLION. CALIFORNIANS AND
THERE WAS A LOT OF. INTRIGUE
ABOUT WHO WOULD GOVERNOR NEWSOM
PICK- FOR SECRETARY OF STATE.
YEAH AND IF YOU WERE NOT ON ANY
LIST THAT I SAW- AND IT WIN HE
MADE THE PICK. I THOUGHT THAT
IS SO OUT OF THE BLUE. AND
MAKES ALL THE SENSE IN THE
WORLD- AND SO- IT IS MY HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE TO SUPPORT YOU-
AND THEN SUPPORT THE MOTION
THAT WAS MADE BY MAJORITY
LEADER VARIOUS- WE'RE GONNA
MISS YOU. I'M GONNA MISS YOUR
WORK ON ON THE HIGHER
EDUCATION- WORK THAT I'VE DONE
THAT YOU'VE BEEN SUCH A BIG A
PARTNER AND THEN I'LL CONTINUE
TO CALL ON SECURE VICE- ON
THOSE MATTERS- BUT- YEAH IT. IS
SO EXCITED TO SEE YOU MOVE ON
TO. TO BIGGER THINGS COMMITTEE
STAFF- WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON THE MOTION THAT THE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE RECOMMENDS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ADVICE AND
CONSENT TO THE APPOINTMENT BY
THE GOVERNOR OF SURELY AND
WEBER. AS THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. BERMAN HI. BERMAN HI.
LOW HI. LOW HI. FLORA HI. FLORA
HI. HOLDEN HOLDEN HI. REYES HI
REYES I. THANK YOU THAT VOTE IS
FIVE NOTHING THE MOST IS
APPROVED. CAN GRADUALLY DR
WEBBER- AND SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS TO COME
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED. THANK YOU
DON'T WANT.